and our crowd out here uh to the
education committee um we're here today
to look at eight um we Bill eight bills
the first one we have in the dock it is
uh HB
1088 um for me this is kind of a sad day
I was brought up in Toronto my
grandparents all went to the University
of Buffalo I was born in Niger Falls New
York and the bills got beat and you know
so and in in the last few seconds on a
field goal miss field goal miss to the
right I just couldn't believe it but so
how did you get yourself to be able to
come here
today well it's been a it's been a
tragedy all along Green Green Bay got
beat too so I lost out on that one and
although although we all to be watching
Detroit they're a strong powerful little
team there so with young people so
hopefully yes so um getting off of that
I I would like to mention to everybody
on the committee here be aware we are
going to be starting to schedule uh
executive sessions and I have executive
sessions SCH scheduled for the 30th and
we'll be starting somewhere around midm
morning and you're going to see a a
whole load of bills on there we won't be
able to exec them all that day but they
will continue to the next day so there
there will be at the bottom of the on
the 30th bills not exact on the on the
30th will continue to the next executive
session which will be the next day uh so
if you only see one bill on the next day
in the calendar that's because all that
other stuff we didn't do on the previous
day will be in that calendar it just
saves our clerk down the hallway from
having to put all the stuff into both
both calendars this has been done many
many times before it's a practice so so
be looking
at exing on the 30th and the
31st uh I haven't set that yet I haven't
set that
yet and so so in in when we're executing
we usually put some time in the front
side those for
caucuses um and we'll probably have that
occur then as well so um so with that
I'd like to go on to
1088 1088 is a bill enabling schools to
main a supply EP
EP nephrine Auto injectors and I'd like
to uh recognize representa Nelson to
present the bill welcome
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to the committee my name is jod Nelson
representing Rockingham 13 and Derry and
this is my very first bill so it's
exciting day for me here um and I am
here um regarding uh my bill uh it which
is regarding the stocking of emergency
epinephrine injectors in school let me
give you a little bit of background to
let you know why this is so important to
me uh when my son was two I nearly
killed him by giving him his first
peanut butter cracker and I learned how
quickly and potentially deadly an
anaphylactic allergy reaction really can
be according to the CDC food allergies
are a growing food safety and public
health concern that affect an estimated
8% of children in the United States
that's one in 13 children and um an
average classroom that's most likely at
least two children in each classroom who
have such a severe
allergy we now have kindergarteners
coming into school for a full day which
is great um but they may be introduced
to new foods during school lunch that
they've never tried before and may have
a reaction to we may have visitors to uh
the school who are exposed to a food
allergen or may have a beasting they
might not have ever known theyve been
allergic and H and will have an EP will
possibly have an anaphylactic reaction
my school nurse Lori Fleming from Hood
Middle School actually saved a child's
life by utilizing a stock epinephrine
auto injector he had a known penut
allergy and did not have a personal
supply of epinephrine auto injector in
school so this another reason why it's
important to have a stock
supply there is language in the
pharmaceutical section of our rsas
pertaining to
epinephrine auto injector use but
there's no clear language in our
education section of the rsas the
purpose of this bill is to provide clear
language and uniform procedure for all
public schools to have a stock of
emergency use epinephrine pens this is
important for school administration
School nurses and also parents to be
able to navigate quickly to our
education laws and be clear on what is
the current law this language is
identical to the language that is
already in statute regarding emergency
use of asthma inhalers and the stocking
of those asthma inhalers and the
language is clear and the process is
running smoothly within our schools
presently our schools are allowed to
contract with drug manifacturers for
free epinephrine Auto injectors however
if a time comes when the program no
longer exists this bill allows for Don
ations to cover the cost of the stock
Auto injectors therefor therefore
providing a way to obtain them without
cost to taxpayers I have the full
support of the New Hampshire school
nurse Association and I know that Morgan
is here from convenient MD to speak on
how this bill will fix a glitch in
schools being able to utilize convenient
MD to facilitate receiving their Auto
injectors thank you for your time and I
am hopeful you will consider OTP on this
Bill thank you very much representa
Nelson are there any questions for the
representative yes representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this bill um a couple
questions I'm hoping you can you know
the process a little bit just to help
determine appropriateness under current
uh rules and law who is allowed to
administer these epip pin at school is
it just a nurse or is it anybody can
administer um Sor sorry moving this a
little bit
um it is the nurse and also um teachers
and school administrators are trained on
um on administering that and um they are
um by law
um what's the word I'm trying to think
of
um they're immune they have immunity
um yes if I may a follow up on that one
um so I notic didn't specify uh in the
bill are we talking about stalking adult
dose epinephrine Auto injectors child
dose Auto injectors or both um that
would be up to the discretion of the
school nurse um I know personally for me
my son um is a big kid so uh early on he
um switched from EpiPen Juniors which is
the lower dose to EpiPen
um for the adult use um I think it's 50
and over which is um the adult usage um
I know it doesn't specifically state in
this and if it would be more clear and
helpful to the committee I would be glad
to amend that to include that in the
Bill thank Youk you repr
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um you're hearing from
the EMTs this morning that's why we're
asking these questions I'm on the rescue
squad which may or may not be actually
on scene when the school nurse might not
be there and our requirement is that we
um match the person to the prescription
and since this is a generic prescription
I want to figure out if this will work
in our protocol in the EMT protocol
that's correct I don't know that but I
can certainly find out and if it would
be helpful for you for me to amend that
to allow that to happen I know um when I
spoke to our school nurse about how um
this usually happens um it the
um General protocol is that the epip pen
is I'm sorry that's that's not the
generic use the epinephrine pen um is uh
delivered immediately and then 911 is
called um and
I literally copied uh I had OS copy the
exact language that's included right now
in law um for uh stocking and and use of
emergency asthma inhalers so I um just
had them um replace emergency asthma
inhalers with epinephrine pens um so I
don't know if um emergency use of asthma
inhalers um at this time is okay with um
the protocol of EMTs or not I it's a
different ball game basically okay okay
representa Damon you had your hand up
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question thank you um and let me
first say it's wonderful that youve
brought this bill forward thank you um
I'm a retired dietitian I worked some in
food allergies and epipens are so
critical and they're expensive people
don't always have what they need so I
have two questions one is whether
there's any statement in regards to
paying attention to the expiration date
because since we don't know how much the
school supply would be utilized and we
know they do expire I think there needs
to be some address to that and the other
question
is whether you have
considered some language around
not not only coordinating with one
for-profit entity convenience an MD
including that but whether schools could
uh have a way to do this besides through
one entity that's not in oh I'm sorry
thank you for the question that's not
included in the language of the bill I
just have a representative here who is
explaining um why this is important for
um the pro current
process they uh I think he can speak
further to it but I don't believe that
um is the only way to obtain a free um
EP through the
companies thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um so this is
permissive language it's May it allows a
school and I'm just wondering if you had
considered at all because of the
severity of the problem as you're
describing it um had you considered um
requiring like why did you choose for it
to be like allowing rather than some
some people might think that requiring
this would be a good idea just your
thoughts on that thank you for your
question I agree with you I thought that
it might be problematic in the sense
that
if there was ever an occasion where the
free um program would not be available
then would it be an unfunded
mandate thank you further questions yes
representative Tanner thank you uh
I was a teacher of physical education
and so beasting were a big thing for me
um and at the time of course I taught in
the Dark Ages but at the time uh we were
on the same protocol as the EMTs that if
the EpiPen did not have the students
name on it then we weren't technically
allowed to give it to us and and I know
the nurse and I struggled because we
were like 10 minutes away from an
ambulance showing up or an EMT showing
up uh whether we would put our licenses
on the line to save a kid because it's
so critical and we did have uh over my
years of teaching several instances
where the EpiPen saved a life so I'm
very happy you brought this bill forward
I think it just needs clarification not
only for the EMTs but for the uh
teachers who are trained I was a first
responder so um I was trained in its use
um but even at that at that time I
couldn't give it uh and I worked at a
high school where we constantly told the
kids to bring in their epens and
constantly they forgot or didn't want to
so um I think you know uh an amendment
like that I'd be willing to to work with
representative dry if you want to and um
to the bill and see if we can put that
in thank you further questions yes
representative Hall thank you Mr chair
and thank you for bringing us forward
and taking my question so I also as an
educator 40 years got trained in this
using oranges and whatever and I prayed
I would never have to use my and I
didn't thank god um but my question is
is there any danger in giving a person
using this on someone who that didn't
really need
it um
I have never heard of a danger in um I'm
not I'm not a medical person or provider
in my research I never have read that um
that there was any um Danger
um complications that occurred with
somebody who um are you talking about
like
accidentally if I I'm thinking the kids
having an allergy but maybe they're not
and like you know if the child has its
own pen then it's probably pretty safe
but let's say you got a kid and let's
say I've got one of these that doesn't
have a name attached to it and I'm
thinking there's a food allergy issue
but there isn't and I you know use the
pen
on a person that that's not really what
the problem was well curious again I'm
not a medical professional but I have
not um heard of that or read of that I
have actually spoken and know friends of
mine who in um trying to give their
administer this to their child they
accidentally poke their finger and um
they're fine
so further questions from the committee
yes represent Bel thank you and that was
an excellent question and I'd like to
follow up just a little bit on that um
you're not going to find many people who
like opado injectors more than me um in
my time as a paramedic I used f a lot
and I personally had my own life saved
by it but at the same time going back to
the last question we heard um when we're
talking about administering to a student
who is not a known allergy so they
you're connecting uh the prescription to
a known allergy you are introducing a
bit of sort of Diagnostics into this
process and there is
there're so these are not nonzero risk
so if they're administered incorrectly
if you happen to hit the artery there's
a good chance of arteriospasm you risk
possibly even losing the limb if you
introduce it to a vein or an artery you
get a big shot of Epi straight to your
heart if there's an unknown heart thing
going on at some history there that
isn't known or perhaps is known you risk
um entering into an arhythmia possibly
cardiac arrest so is there knowing that
is there concern con ER with people who
were not trained in Diagnostics a nurse
would certainly be trained in this but
I'm more concerned about just teachers
possibly introducing this uh
unnecessarily thank you for your
question this is already in statute um
in the pharmaceutical section this is
already happening in the schools so um I
don't uh know that
um that I I
um I don't I I mean I think that it's
um it's a not a pro I don't know I don't
know how to answer your question exactly
other than it's in statute and it's
already in practice and I have not heard
of any uh complications with that I I oh
thank you are there further questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you very much thank you uh Morgan
frostino
you were here real early
today yeah thank
you um thank you everyone for taking the
time to uh listen to my um input on this
bill um uh so I'm from can you just yeah
introduce yourself oh y my name is
Morgan I'm from uh convenient MD uh we
are a Healthcare Company we're based in
uh Portsmith we have uh 14 location
urgent care locations throughout the
state as well as a primary care Care
office um and one of the ways that we
try to give back to our communities is
through our school owners partnership
program uh through this program one of
the free resources that we provide to
schools is we help them obtain um stock
medications um a very uh common request
from schools is um for help utilizing
the E pen for schools program this is a
national program uh that donates two um
twin packs of EB pens per School uh per
calendar year um and so we uh we help
these schools by uh writing the
prescription which is required to obtain
the devices uh we place the order and
then uh currently the way uh that the
law is written in New Hampshire uh it
must um in conjunction with the policy
of the uh the facilitator of the program
it must come to the uh prescriber uh to
then dispense to the school um and so uh
it that creates um some inefficiency um
or let me back up um I had looked looked
into why this might be the case in New
Hampshire um because uh we also have
clinics in Maine and Massachusetts and I
learned that Most states in the country
um the epipens go directly to the
schools but the way after inquiring with
the Board of Pharmacy I submitted a
request for declaratory ruling
essentially what they informed me was
the way the current law is written is
that um because the this facilitator is
licensed as a wholesaler wholesalers are
only permitted to sell directly to
schools it does not have any it it the
language is specific in that it only
permits the sale and because these
epipens are being donated to the schools
um it it would prohibit the school from
working directly with the facilitator of
the program um byid Pharma um I and I
did uh I I know I'm getting ahead of
myself I uh there should be copies of
the uh summary on in front of all of you
if if you want to follow along um uh so
essentially um what this would do is um
this would make it easier for schol
schools to obtain the epipens because it
could get shipped directly to the school
um currently when it gets shipped to the
clinic it requires that our Clinic staff
receive and manage and communicate to
the school nurse when the epipens are
there um you know occasionally things
get misplaced and sometimes there's a
little bit of panic because as we uh as
we discussed earlier epipens are very
expensive and so um these are donated
EpiPen so I mean we always you know we
always manage to to uh to get the
devices to the school nurse but um so so
that's one one issue that may come up um
another issue is uh these School nurses
are usually um obtaining the devices on
their personal time driving sometimes uh
depending on where the school nurse is
and where they have a willing prescriber
it can be well over an hour round trip
um on a weekend or after school things
like
that um and
um and it may may a uh increase uh
potentially the availability of um
schools who can utilize this program
because a if if a um if a ordering
provider all I have to do is write a
prescription they may be more amendable
to uh assisting the school and Ting the
devices as opposed to writing the
prescription and receiving the shipment
and managing it and communicating to the
school nurse that they've arrived and
asking them to come pick it up um so
essentially um this uh the language in
this bill would um uh make it clear that
School nurses could work directly with a
third party that is looking to provide
the epipens at uh no cost
um to the
school thank you very much are there
questions yes represent Penton now thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um from the prescriber
perspective what is the risk to the
prescriber because I notice in your
testimony you say um it would increase
the availability of stock epipens and
mean more willing prescribers um for
this purpose so yeah so I'm just simp
meant that they wouldn't have to receive
the devices to their location and hold
on to them for the school nurse to come
pick up um because this program if this
bill were to pass the uh the EpiPen for
schools program instead of shipping to
the prescriber to the end dispense of
the school would be able to ship
directly to the school as they do in in
many other
states I guess my question is more
related to like malpractice risk to the
prescriber so if you write a
prescription for a blanket prescription
for the epen to be used used does that
ever
um in turn effect if they're used
inappropriately can the prescriber ever
be litigated for malpractice I'm not
sure what the what the logistics are
they are were the concerns
um yeah I'll just leave it at that I
guess I'm not
sure thank you very much representative
beler thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for your testimony on this um just
to clarify this program is it's not
specifically your program as convenient
MD but it's it's a program that you're
helping to assist with and that they're
donated not from Community MD but the
manufacturer correct y it is a national
program tens of thousands of uh schools
uh every year utilize this program
excellent and if I may have a quick
follow up on that just to um clarify so
these are donated by the manufacturer
but do the participating um
organizations such as yours receive any
compensation as a part of participating
in this program we do not receive
anything excellent thank you
y further questions yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question just to clarify so
your program is with the Branded epipens
not generic no um we we our our program
our school nurse partnership program is
we help School nurses with a variety of
things for for free it's just a way to
build Goodwill and give back to the
community and pro promote Health if a
school nurse requests our our help in
utilizing this National program this
National EpiPen for schools program
that's the school nurse making the
request to obtain the EpiPen and we
simply help them obtain it by writing
the prescription receiving the delivery
of the
devices
oh so do you have uh
capacity to help School nurses get
generic ones as opposed to Brandon
absolutely we could certainly write it
for description it would just require
them to obtain them some other way
whether that would be trying to obtain
them from a pharmacy or an online vendor
or something like that um we we
certainly could it's just that because
this is the free donation program this
is the Lion Share of the requests for
epinephrine devices that we get thank
you represent dry thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question um
can you shed any light on helping others
the
the people other than the school nurse
who might be able in a position to give
this uh shot to match the prescription
to the patient um we my understanding is
that the bo the Board of Pharmacy uh has
uh said that this these should be
written in the name of a school for
emergency use um so I unfortunately I
don't know what the specifics are in
terms of the training for uh
administrators and teachers okay thank
you yeah any further
questions thank you very much thank you
I do not have any other pink cards for
this bill 1088 so I'm closing the
hearing and we will in a couple minutes
go into the next
bill which will be
I don't have any I think they went that
way if you find any I'd like a personal
copy I have one for the
um yeah you want to take
mine we can have some copies right no
problem
yeah it's got to the
draw
one
second
I
usually really breakf I have to do
this okay it is 9:30 we're ready to go
ahead with the next hearing the next
hearing is on HP
1553 this is relative to establishing a
pilot program under the Department of
Education to offer spelling to
communicate services to students with
autism and
aasia um so uh with that I'd like to
recognize the prime sponsor Bill uh
representative Jim
kofalt welcome to
education thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
uh for hearing my testimony on this bill
for the record my name is Jim kofalt I
represent the towns of Wilton Temple and
new ipswitch Hillsboro County District
um so I'd like to begin by just
introducing what spelling to communicate
is um it's a methodology that has been
developed that teaches people with
Autism and
araxia how to spell uh by Point how to
spell out words by pointing to letters
on a letter board um aaia is a condition
in which somebody cannot speak or cannot
speak
reliably and one of the founding um
assumptions of spelling to communicate
is that this is essentially a motor
skills deficit not a cognitive deficit
and so um there is also an assumption
that every person person is um with
autism is is fully as intelligent as
anybody else unless uh unless proven
otherwise so I want you to imagine for a
moment that you have never been able to
talk that you are fully aware of
everything that's going on in the world
you understand language just as well as
the next
person um you have complex thoughts and
emotions but you have never been able to
express those reliably
what would that be
like there are tablet devices
applications various kinds of tools that
help people with Autism to be able to
communicate simple things what they want
for
dinner if they need to go to the
bathroom um what they'd like to do
today but there's really nothing uh in
those in those tools that enable
somebody to communicate complex thoughts
the other challenge I think that a lot
of people with Autism run into is um
because they have a a specific neurology
they often are not inclined to make eye
contact so people make this assumption
that they're sort of off in their own
world consequently a lot of people look
at people with Autism and they think
that there's a a cognitive deficiency
when in fact that turns out not to be
true at
all now I want you to imagine what it
would be like if you've lived your
entire life that way and suddenly you
break out of that
prison what would that be
like uh there's a young man named
Gregory Tino who is a blogger who who
described his experience this
way um the year I started to live was
2017 the month was May the time was the
moment I learned to spell on the letter
board
my world turned upside down in that
moment never again would people think I
was stupid or had the mind of a
toddler the look on my mom's face is
forever burned in my
memory I would love to relive that again
and again this is the best moment of my
life so
far there are no words to describe the
depths of my
gratitude this is like winning the
lottery like winning the lottery that
you've always dreamed
of I first found out about spelling to
communicate a little over a year ago
when a friend of mine um shared news
about her daughter and she said Jim
Miracles are happening um I think you're
going to hear from her today and so um I
will will let her tell her own
story this bill would create a modest
pilot program available through our
schools uh and if passed it could
potentially make New Hampshire the first
state in the country to implement
spelling to communicate or to make it
available uh through our
schools I would like to point out a few
arguments I think that you're likely to
hear um in opposition to the
bill um the first has to do with
something called facilitated
communication there was a methodology
some years ago called facilitated
communication that was
discredited and this is not facilitated
communication nevertheless the the
criticism uh that that some make against
spell spelling to communicate is that
the instructor may lead the speller to
certain letters so that the
communication really isn't coming from
the client at all it's coming from the
teacher or the
instructor in 20 20 there was a study
published in nature in the journal
Nature that actually used itracking
devices and they were able to um
positively discern that that in fact
people's eyes were going to the letters
before their their hand was going to the
letter so um so there is scientific
evidence that this is not facilitated
communication furthermore there are
numerous people who have actually
graduated from the letter board to a
keyboard there is no facilitator and
they are communicating complex thoughts
um that includes some people uh who
write who write blogs uh several
non-speakers who write blogs um whom I
will mention in a moment so I think the
uh the the notion that this is
facilitated communication or similar to
facilitated communication uh is quite
easy to
debunk the second criticism is that
there are no um long-term expansive
studies
uh proving that spelling to communicate
is effective in fact there are quite a
few studies um in process uh I think
that the researchers are catching up to
uh the reality of the experience that
people out there in the world are having
um in order to do an expansive study you
would need an expansive population of
people who've been through this program
and I would assert that uh New Hampshire
could potentially be uh on the Leading
Edge of that research uh but the bottom
line is that if you hear from the
families of people who have been through
this and whose lives have been changed
by this I believe that you'll come to
the same conclusion I did uh which is
that we should be making this available
now and uh letting people Avail
themselves of
it people like Gregory Tino whom I
mentioned
before um he laments the fact that
people once thought he had the intellect
of a toddler he has by the way published
four books now on Amazon and he writes a
a a
Blog uh Vincent renella is another
prominent blogger non-speaker he has a
strong interest in politics and he
aspires to be the first non-speaker
elected to the United States
Senate Elizabeth Bonker has never spoken
but she learned to communicate using a
letter board and now a tablet device in
2022 she graduated as the valid
dictorian of Rollins College and was
featured in People magazine she's also
the founder of communication for all a
nonprofit organization whose mission is
to ensure that all non-speakers with
autism have access to communication and
education Jamie Handley who did not
communicate prior to the age of 19
verbally co-authored a book with his
father and a handful of other
non-speaking
friends and that book became the basis
for the award-winning document mentary
spellers which I strongly encourage all
of you to check
out there are many other stories I think
you will hear a few of them
today um I want to strongly encourage
you to to pass this bill I I um I do
want to mention that this was drafted
very very late in the process in fact I
submitted the LSR and it was not on the
list of lsrs so it fell through the
cracks um I I reached out out to OS and
uh and they corrected that but it was
among the last of the bills to to be
drafted so um I will acknowledge that um
some may see fit to to make some
amendments to the bill I would be very
happy to work with anybody on this
committee who is interested in doing
that uh
specifically um I have heard some people
question whether or not the acceptance
of a grant would be optional to a school
District I am entirely open to making an
acceptance of a grant optional to the
school district um if that is something
that people would like to see um changed
in the bill um that concludes my
introduction and I will take questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions represent dry then
representative cascaden thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you describe the process a
little bit is this something that we're
paying for a person specially trained to
come and work in the school and are they
one-on-one um you know distributed
oneon-one with the students um it is a
one-on-one process and again there are
people here who can probably describe it
in in further detail um it takes some
time
for uh for someone to let's say come up
to speed or open up as they as they
describe it um so there's a very
specific methodology around sort of
getting them from you know from from
zero to to 30 and then eventually moving
on from there it's also a lot of hard
work um you know I've seen people
spellers who are answering Q&A sessions
and it can be a fairly exhausting
process um so it's it's it's a long
process and I I believe there are also
videos out there quite a few videos out
on YouTube um some of which I think
people in this room will probably share
with the committee as well um that can
enable you to actually see what that
process looks
like well let's Okay quickly follow up
because then I want to get to the
there's a number of cards questions we
have here practitioner would stay with
that student so every school would have
to have a different person no um thank
you the idea would be that um because
there are a few practitioners in New
Hampshire that I'm aware of there are
some in surrounding states as well um
generally the the activity could take
place at school at a school or or really
anywhere else um but no it would not be
that that person would not be a sort of
Resident at the at the school thank
represent cascaden thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question has
this program been vetted by the American
speech language hearing
Association um the American speech
language hearing Association um is
uh It generally is opposed to spelling
to
communicate because they they raise the
concern of facilitated
communication um again I believe that
that concern is easily debunked um and I
would also underscore that this program
would not take away from any other
program out there uh this would be a net
new money it's a very modest start it's
a pilot program um and if you read the
the the very end of the bill it as a
pilot program it it is repealed
automatically after after three
years representative Mila represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this bill um to follow up
on rep Cason's question I'm looking at
the Asher website uh vly they warn
against this practice and I've looked
into this to understand why and they
offer a number of rationale some of
which may be reasonable but the primary
rationale they offer for being against
this is that they can consider
communication to be an individual human
right and they believe that by using an
aid to assist somebody you are actually
depriving the child of his or her
autonomy but wouldn't it wouldn't it be
true that if this
works they would be better to
communicate with the help of an aid than
to not be able to communicate at
all I'm I'm going to say that I I I have
heard stories of from family members
parents in particular
whose adult children with
autism they they basically have have
lived in this fear what's going to
happen to my son or daughter when I'm
gone and for the first time they feel
like their son or daughter is fully able
to communicate and that they will be
okay that to me is profound I I think
that there is there is a profound sense
that this enables autonomy and and um
again I'll let some some of the other
folks speak to to that point Thank you
represent Damon thank you Mr chair thank
you for bringing this forward and taking
my question could you speak to us about
how someone becomes a certified s2c
practitioner I can try but again it's
it's a my knowledge of it is not going
to be as detailed as some of the other
people in the room um there is an
application process and
um it's I believe the cost is around
$33,000 to become
certified
um and I believe that the the on-site
training I believe that there is on-site
training in Atlanta is where that that
takes place I may be mistaken about that
there is also a coaching process
generally when someone is a new
practitioner uh there's a mentoring
process that follows that and often
includes
um yeah let's say a kind of co- teing
relationship with someone else who is uh
is more experienced in the methodology
thank
you further questions yes represent
cordelli uh thank you thank you
representative kofalt um I think as you
pointed out there is some
controversy about this method and I I
think um when you talk about facilitated
communication um I've also SE seen it
referred to as a rapid response method
or rapid prompting method um which is um
um well per semi-personal experien in
that my daughter is a special ed teacher
um outside of Austin and um she has used
uh letter board or spelling board um
however her students um are not
functionally able to use
it um there was also a lady in Austin
who
uses this facilitated communication and
has convinced um people that um uh
anyone can um learn to communicate using
this method um but only
she can use this method she's the only
one who knows how to use this method
um uh
so I I've also read that there is one
study which is maybe the study that
you're referring to um I'm just curious
about um other studies that show that um
this method is not there's no uh
facilitator bias in the method in in um
uh that the uh student can actually uh
do this themselves and uh are there
other studies besides that one that you
mentioned I'll I'll let people who who
follow me okay answer that I as
regarding facilitated communication I'll
say that if you watch some of the
YouTube videos of people who are very
early in the process you will see a
coach patiently working with them kind
of knowing what it is that they're going
to spell if you see people who have
graduated to higher levels and are
further along with the process you will
see them sitting at a computer keyboard
tapping out answers to questions where
there is no facilitator sitting next to
them or prompting them in any way
whatsoever so I I again I I think it's
it's it's fairly obvious uh just by
observation um but again I will let
others uh answer the question of of
formal studies in further have one quick
followup uh yes um one question on the
bill language itself there is an
appropriation for 120
$5,000 um but you're also making
non-public schools available for Grants
from this appropriation is that correct
and and your reasoning for including
non-public schools um because I I don't
think it should be limited so I you know
I I wanted to make it available to as
many as many people as possible um one
of the people in the room today who's
going to be testifying is is a
homeschooler um so they're currently
private paying for it um it's it's kind
of a heavy lip it's not it's not it's
not a lot of money but for somebody
who's on a very tight budget trying to
to look after her adult daughter it's
it's not easy um so yes I wanted to make
it available to as wide a group as
possible are there further questions
represent
Damon thank you do you have any
information on how many students would
be likely to be eligible for this
program I don't unfortunately no further
questions representative Pell thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question my original question was how
many students in the state might be
eligible for a program like that but
that's not the question I'm going to ask
after listening to representative
cordell's um question I as he was
speaking I was thinking about um a great
example we have of someone who
possibly
um became very successful as a result of
facilitated communication and that made
me think of um shoot Helen Keller and
the assistance she had with Anne
Sullivan and would you agree that maybe
this might be a new breakthrough in
teaching people how to communicate she
certainly had to be facilitated in order
to become a very successful author and
leader in our country I I absolutely
believe that this is a breakthrough I
think when you hear from people who've
who whose lives have been affected by it
and the impact that it has on them and
how it takes somebody from being in a
prison of
non-communication to having autonomy and
dignity and to me it's it's a world of
difference and you hear that um you'll
hear it today I think and if you if you
watch the movie spellers or if you read
the book
underestimated you will hear those
stories over and over again
further questions not see any thank you
very much thank you uh for the following
people I'm going to limit discussion of
three minutes per person uh we have a
number of cards here so I'd like to
invite Pamela
cook good
morning
sorry about that um my handwriting can
be pretty bad so I apologize for that my
name is actually Patricia Cook okay and
I'm from London da New Hampshire and my
friends teased me I should have been a
doctor um I am the mother of four sons
and I have been fortunate enough to
watch them all grow up in into men and
I've heard them speak their first words
and see them Advance into speaking into
sentences uh um but imagine regressing
and only being able to speak in one or
two word
phrases that's what happened to my my
youngest son
Liam um when he was two and a half years
old so I felt like I lost my
son he can no longer Express himself and
was using only those one or two words to
get his his basic needs
met so imagine he couldn't he couldn't
ever tell me when he was hurt either
emotionally or
physically um and he got he did get sick
um you know numerous times when he was
young he got stre through throat a
number of times and could never tell me
that he was hurting but I would end up
getting the STP throat and then we would
know that Liam had strep throat we would
get him tested and it was always him it
was not none of the other boys it was
always Liam because the other ones
obviously could tell me if they were
sick um he broke his arm we didn't know
till the next day when it all swelled up
um you know CU initially right after the
injury you know he had he had he had his
uncle fall on top of him actually um we
didn't realize it was broken um he ended
up in the hospital twice in fourth grade
uh because he stopped eating and
drinking and you know I had a fight with
the doctors at Elliot Hospital to get
him admitted and treated because they
felt it was all
behavioral um he ended up being severely
constipated the doctor said there was
absolutely no more room for food to to
go into his intestines so they could
have burst and all that bacteria would
have ended up in his bloodstream so he
could have died all because he couldn't
tell us what was going on with his
body
um um he Liam's now 19 years old he was
diagnosed with autism and intellectual
disability when he was 5 years
old um you know
I never really believed the latter
because I always felt he was intelligent
just that he just couldn't get it out
you he didn't have the the speech to do
that um he has been in speech therapy
standard traditional speech therapy
since he was three years old he had it
he's had it in school he's had he has a
private speech therapist so he has it
multiple times a week he's been
evaluated at Boston Children's Hospital
autism language program and his language
is only increased minimally
um he uses the same phrases daily you
know they just wrote phrases like you
ask him a question I don't know um when
he sees me the first thing he says to me
is what are you making for dinner this
this could be at 8:00 in the
morning okay um but you know he found
the spellers program in May we've been
doing it um and now I feel like I'm
getting my son back I know I can hear
him again um he was able to tell me in a
Christmas card that this is has been the
best year of his life
um you know he was able to tell us you
know he's able to demonstrate his
intelligence he told us that triom 21 is
commonly known as Down syndrome when
asked for an antonym for virtuous he
spelled out the word
malevolent um your your time is up oh
I'm sorry yeah so I I I asked for you to
support this bill of 1553 um to give him
you his him people like him their voices
and for them to be able to access class
you know
education um that's at their level of
intelligence are you willing to take any
questions sure other questions from the
committee one represent Woodcock thank
you CH good morning thank you here I
appreciate can you tell me how long you
son's been involved in the program he
just started in the end of May of this
year excuse me of 2023 and you're
thinking about that his success so far
oh yes I I see it he I every every
session he blows my mind with with what
he knows and and and um great thank you
so much appreciate itk are there further
questions thank you very much thank you
I appreciate you listening you're
welcome uh Karen
Rosenberg good morning good morning uh
chairman lad and members of the
committee I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center I've held this position for just
a little over two years and prior to
that from the fall of 2005 until I
started my job as policy director I
provided individual representation for
children among other things but children
in special education cases and I'm here
in to testify in opposition to this bill
not because I'm in I'm going to say
anything about spells to communicate
that is far beyond my expertise but
because I think that it sets a poor
precedent school districts are already
required to evaluate children who for
special education they're supposed to
evaluate them in all areas of suspected
disability and have by qualified
evaluators to determine one whether the
student meets the criteria as a student
with a disability but also to determine
what services and supports that child
needs including whether they need
assistive technology in order to receive
a free appropriate public education fape
something you're all familiar with so
the idea of diverting funds to one
particular program or incentivizing one
particular program undermines that
fundamental principle of idea that
schools evaluate children to by
qualified people to determine what
program they need and what is the most
effective intervention and to make that
intervention available to students and I
know having worked at the disability
rights Center where you know people
don't call us if they're happy that
schools we get calls from parents who
are dissatisfied with what schools are
doing to address their children's needs
and there are procedures in place do
process complaint procedures for parents
to follow when schools aren't doing what
they're supposed to be doing to address
needs
um but just giving money to parents for
a program without an
evaluation it it may actually cause
schools to send children to this program
instead of providing the program that
actually more closely aligns to what
their individualized needs are so I
think that's problematic I can tell you
that I've represented children with
communication issues and AAC is
incredibly powerful it can be so
powerful but over the years that I've
represented students with communication
issues I I don't know that any of them
have been prescribed the same program
I've had students start with something
as rudimentary as objects like when they
really didn't understand communication
at all so and literally a physical
object to communicate I need to eat
here's a spoon I need to use the
facilities here's a you know little toy
toilet up through students who are
communicating at a much higher level
using more sophisticated devices so um
you know children do need the
opportunity to be evaluated and to
communicate in the best way for them and
um this wouldn't do that and for that
reason we oppos this bill and I'm really
happy to take any questions you might
have thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here for this testimony you
brought up a very important point that I
want to just drill down on a little bit
and you talked about the um the possible
need for technology assisted um learning
and the provision of funds for that but
in this program an aid holding a board
that doesn't seem like a technology to
me so would that be Avail would that be
available to be funded under current um
law on this or would that not be yeah it
could be funded like I said it doesn't
when you think about assisted technology
you know we think about like high-tech
but assist of Technology can also be
quite low Tech so there are students
that um their technology might be like I
said something as rudimentary as a
client of mine who really was so had so
much ground to make up that that
particular student was given little
objects that's not high-tech right
eventually that student graduated to a
much more high-tech communication but
yes if that communic whatever is
appropriate and what that student needs
to obtain a free appropriate public
education
then that is what the school has an
obligation to provide and if I may just
to just to drill down uh so not not just
the board itself but you could fund the
aid having the aid there yeah if that's
yeah there's a there's actually a
section in an IEP that describes what
kind of if it's specialized instruction
what they need if it's an auxiliary Aid
or supplementary service they need so
yes all of those things that the student
would need can be funded through the IEP
thank you further question questions
from the committee representative pill
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and for being here so
I just want to um I'm asking you to
reiterate your concern is probably in
section um Roman numeral 2 where it says
under this program any parent so not
just a student with an IEP who's H
already
having who where the school already has
concerns about their ability is that
what you're referring to but can you
tell me so I'm on page one Roman
two have been an application yeah I mean
I mean one thing one concern I have is
that schools that aren't doing their job
that want to kind of get out from under
their obligations under federal law
might be incentivized to say to the
parent oh your child is having problems
sure we'll give you this
$4,500 and you can arrange for your
child's communication needs to be met
and then we won't need to fund an
evaluation which is required under
federal law we won't need to consider
what is the most appropriate
intervention for your child so yeah
that's a
concern we well the thing just has a
mind itself um further
questions thank you very much thank you
all I'd like to call forward Lori
Rogers
thank you chairman thank you committee
members for allowing us to testify or
from you to testify this morning I am
here in to please ask you to please
support hb1 1553 so I'm the mother of a
33-year-old son Craig he's a
non-speaking uh young man with autism
and apraxia so his autism and aaia
prevents him from speaking the way I am
right now the messages from his brain to
his mouth to these muscles is
disconnected so what spelling to
communicate does is takes this very fine
motor skill of verbal speech and puts it
into the very gross motor skill of
pointing to letters to spell out words
phrases and sentences to say what he
wants to communicate it's so so simple
it's
amazing
so without a communication device like
s2c um Craig if you had seen Craig you
would probably think he was unaware of
his surroundings or that he was not
intelligent because he could not speak
with tools like this he can now be open
and not trapped in his own head with his
own thoughts and pains and desires and
wants and needs he now has this method
to tell us and I'm going to share with
you two major ways that has impacted his
life and our lives the first one is
health and
wellbeing before s2c we never knew
whether he was sick had a headache a
throat sore throat a stomach ache now
with s2c the last time we saw his doctor
he was able to communicate I have a
stomach ache she examined him and
realized he had a hiatal hernia which
was treated he also told another
physician um that he wanted to learn how
to calm down and heal his anxiety so we
went through different methods of
meditation we taught him how to become
more regulated and he told us that
exercise helps his anxiety so exercise
has become a major role in his daily
activities which is amazing um the the
second part is since education
before s2c we call it or spelling to
communicate he could display very
rudimentary basic academic things now we
are learning how smart he is he is doing
High School level and college level
course material and answering the
questions on the letter board right now
his goal is to graduate from this letter
board which yes I have to hold for him
as he points to the letters to graduate
to a laminated board then
independently type on a keyboard to say
and have his own autonomy in what he
wants to say so thank you for hearing my
testimony and also I feel it's going to
make the teachers lives so much easier
if they can actually communicate with
their students where they can't
now thank you thank you very much other
questions represent Miler thank you Mr
chair thank you for being there sure is
that a letter board you have with you
yes how does it work so if Neil were
Craig and I said to Craig I usually I
ask him what he appreciates when I see
him every day and we work together I'll
ask him what he appreciates and I say
all right Craig can you tell me on the
board would you appreciate can you
please move back because you're too
close and you know he's a lefty so it's
hands over I'm going to use my right
okay so and then he'll go right to the
board and he'll answer and I say okay
hey find your letter scan the board and
he'll tell me I am appreciating like one
day he said I appreciate Beth who is his
practitioner and then I said okay well
why do you appreciate Beth and he
answered because because she has
patience with me I'm not touching him
I'm not coaching him I just say all
right go that's what I do now yes when
he was first starting Remember When
wouldn't put your four-year-old out on a
two- wheel bike without training wheels
first right and let them just go they
need training wheels too so in this
method they need training wheels they
need facilitation just like heler Keller
needed it so initially you are guiding
them scan the board scan the board find
your letter find your letter and then
they graduate to no prompting at all and
no nothing from us from their
practitioner or from their communication
regulation partner which is what I am
now um and then they then they tra then
they move on to the laminated board and
then independently on the
keyboard so thank you follow yes follow
up so excuse me so
initially your son has to learn the
letters how no he knows the letters
excellent question he knows the letters
he needs to learn the most M planning
remember CU aaia is that disconnect from
your motor cortex to the muscles of your
body he needs to learn this the the
motor planning to find the letters and
the motor planning to tell his eyes
where to go your eyes have like nine
muscles in each eye so the disconnect
between your motor cortex and your eye
muscles is there too when you have
autism and praia so we have to help his
tell his eyes move your eyes move move
your eyes scan the board he already
knows the letters he already knows many
complex words and sentences and and
ideas and thoughts and all that jazz um
it's it's the motor planning that's
missing that's the piece that's missing
thank you
thing repr cordelli yes thank you for
being here and congratulations um for
the story about your son um did he
receive um this instruction with the um
therapist facilitator via an IEP at
school no Craig is 33 we discovered this
in
2022 he was
31 he had speech therapy three times a
week every week of his life in public
education but what was missing there
was he had a pracy
so no one was working on that disconnect
him his brain to his body um and they
expected him to verbally speak which he
could not
do or or they were teaching him to point
to things on a laminated visual board
right so on a laminated visual board you
might have 20 choices of things you want
what if you didn't want any of those 20
choices so you know there were Foods or
activities or what have you but let's
say he wanted to go run intervals at the
Y that wasn't a choice on the board so
you're very limited in what you can
choose when you have a laminated picture
board let's say or an iPad with maybe 30
pictures on it what if you don't want
any of those 30 things you know so this
gives him the opportunity to really
Express with 26 letters you can say
anything in the world that you want and
oh by the way he knows Spanish so he
does it in Spanish too I have no idea
how but yeah thank you sure further
questions represent
Woodcock good morning thank you so much
for being here um I'm assuming based on
your dialogue that you have been the
trainer for you son oh I wish no his
trainer his
practitioner is a woman in New Hampshire
her name is Beth freed she is a trained
through I ask i- as.org trained
practitioner she works with Craig but
she also trained me how to do this also
I took a parent course through I ask so
to get trained as a practitioner it is
about $3,000 it takes about three month
uh six months and you do it uh on Zoom
virtually and you're also going out into
the community and and working with um
non-speaking individuals as a parent
cohort I went through the class it took
me about three months that was $750 and
I got trained but I also sit with Beth
when she's working with Craig and she
also coaches me on my method it is so
strict I ask has strict strict
methodology they never want you
to force your thought or your will or
your what you think the child or adults
should say on that person it's very
strict training very strict
protocols you yeah thank you sure
further further questions we have more
cards here so yes representative
Ford thank
you thank you for taking my question
sure would you tell us a little bit
about his reading
experience yes when he was
younger I used to take take
books rewrite the sentences for him in
probably like a 20 point font cut them
out paste them into the book so that he
could follow the words and read it so
when he was five or six or seven years
old he could
read but the font was very large so
we're going back to that aaia piece
now he he can I don't know how to
explain it but he can he can
read but the typing is so small that
when you have a praia to follow those
words and letters and have your eyes
move each line of the text it's very
difficult so when we're doing lessons
with him now we read the lesson to him
and ask him he's not reading anything
he's listening so the other day we were
doing a a lesson on courage and I read
the I read the lesson and I asked him a
question about courage and he answers
the question based on what he's heard
not not what he's read so we listen to
books on Audible and I ask him questions
about the books or the material we just
read what he's just
heard yeah thank you thank you no we're
not going to have a
followup um I'm gonna no further
questions thank you sure thank you
everyone like to uh invite Wendy
liban
hello thank you for having me chairman
lad and the rest of the group I'm Wendy
lbrand I'm a speech language pathologist
in New Hampshire I have been a speech
language pathologist for 23 years
actually 24 years um I graduated from
UNCC in 2000 and became an AAC
specialist I was also the president of
the North Carolina speech language
hearing Association and I served on the
Massachusetts speech language hearing
board I've also presented at Asha in the
past and at many state
conventions I'm here in opposition to
The
Spill this is based on pseudo science I
know that previous people that have
spoken have said it's not but it does
not allow independent communication from
the person with a
disability all speech pathologists
hopefully presume confidence and we also
want independent ways for students to
communicate
and as a speech pathologist that has
worked in the schools my entire career
I've seen many failed attempts at that
well-meaning
attempts and then I've seen many many
very successful attempts the original
speaker the first person that spoke said
that
um students could never speak in full
languages and that's not true um
augmented of alternative communication
systems lamp in
particular Toby dbox touch chat there's
many research articles
longstanding that indicate that these
are languages and can be used with
Independence to allow people to
independently Express various viewpoints
even though there is a limited icon set
present I'm happy to take any questions
oh wait I want to say one more thing
Asha um rarely takes position statements
and it has a whole page if you haven't
looked at their website Asha warns
against rapid prompt method or spelling
to
communicate and there's a chart at the
end about why it warns against
it um and I'm happy to provide you this
copy if you'd like it's just the print
off from the
website um but it warns against it
because it denies people their human
right of independent communication it
always requires an aid for prompting and
prompts are not phased out it does not
align with existing research and
long-standing knowledge about
communication development and learning
it holds the potential for
misappropriated messages and false
claims of abuse it replaces effective
individualized communication support and
educational opportunities by diverting
resources which is exactly what we're
talking about here today time and money
to ineffective technique it gives false
hope and promotes unsubstantiated claims
of unlocking hidden
talents now I'm done thank you very much
I do have a question for you I have a a
daughter who is a speech pathologist
with their sees and she practices in
Myrtle Beach um but I asked her were you
informed about facilitated communication
when you were taking your master's
program at University South Carolina
Medical School Charleston she said no um
can you explain why that is not uh being
taught at the level higher ed through
many of our teacher preparation Pro
Speech Pathology programs mhm well I
can't speak to your daughter's
experience it should be being taught but
as you know should and are different
words um I went to UNCC Chapel Hill and
graduated in 2000 and it definitely was
taught to me previous to that I went to
UVA undergrad which is an educational
program and majored in communication
disorders and it was also taught to me
there that facilitated communication is
s pseudo science because it requires
another adult to prompt you all this is
not to say that alphabet boards are not
assisted technology they are it's just
that they need to be able to be used
independently so if they're mounted and
the person is using their eye gaze or
their pointer independently without
somebody else touching them or prompting
them then that can be considered
assisted technology that's what the
representative for disability rights was
speaking about thank you further
questions from the committee represent
Bel thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here for this testimony I want to
drill down a little bit on this concept
of independent communication and I want
to do so by an analogy and asking you
what you think of it let's say there's a
bill and it's going to have a extreme
impact on this one individual's life and
they want to be able to be here to
testify for that bill but they only
speak
Portuguese would it be more appropriate
for them to come here and testify on
that bill with the help of an
interpreter to let us know what they're
saying or would that be under this value
judgment would that be a negative item
because they themselves are not
independently communicating to this
committee well I think the use of an
interpreter for second language or a
non-native English speaker is very
different from the use of a
facilitator so an interpreter takes what
you say and translates that but you're
say the Portuguese speaker in this
instance would be saying that
independently The Interpreter wouldn't
be saying now I think you should say
blank
so they're very different things people
can independently even very young
children communicate
using AAC and assisted technology
without prompting from an adult does do
I mean to say that you never prompt
people when they're learning no but you
use AED language input which is more of
a
demonstration of what of how to use a
system you would never expect an AAC
user to learn to use an AAC system by
just plopping it down in front of them
and saying now use
it but the way you do that is through
demonstrating it on yours and over time
the person realizes oh this has power it
has communicative power you're not
manipulating their arms or doing those
sorts of things thank you repr
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question I don't have any experience
with this so so I'm trying to
understand in some of the cases
presented
people who were 20 or 30 years
nonverbal apparently finding this
helpful and I am enough of a scientist
to appreciate that anecdotal report is
not data and
science but perhaps you could
help us better
understand if if those folks
had conventional speech therapy on an
ongoing and what would seem to be
comprehensive
basis and didn't become able to
communicate with
that why we wouldn't entertain this as
like one of the tools in the
toolbox I think it's a slippery slope um
of course you want hope for
communication and you always have
presumed competence which is exactly
what the other people were saying people
autistic individuals people with the
pracy of speech you must presume
confidence because you don't know
there's no way to know their cognitive
level they cannot
communicate um so both speech
pathologists in more traditional AAC
methods and in spelling to communicate
presume competence is there and there's
no debate about whether or not letter
boards can be used as assisted
technology um regarding having many
years of speech therapy and it not
working I I'm hesitant to speak to that
because I don't know the particular case
one example might be that the person
never had a an effective AAC evaluation
and so therefore never developed
independent
communication I would hate to think
that's true but I I'm and this is a
guess because I don't I don't know the
exact case you're speaking about I hope
that answers your
question thank you uh
yes that is helpful could you also give
us some perspective on What proportion
of
nonverbal folks with autism and Oro
praxia become able to communicate
independently well that's hard to say I
will say that the incidence of people
using AAC Across the Nation is
1% so it is a very low incidence but it
but that is not to say that it is not
very important to the people it happens
like it's it's gut-wrenching for parents
and families to have children that they
cannot communicate with and as a speech
pathologist the that's why I went in
into the profession I also became
certified as an assisted technology
professional through resna which is the
governing body of North America I mean
this was my job like my passion was to
help people communicate that could
not further represent dryan thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
we heard a few examples here of people
who have graduated basically to um
keyboards and things which is not
prompted communication so wouldn't this
just be considered a step on the way to
getting to non prompted
communication for some people I guess it
can be but the idea that you are
dependent on a facilitator at any point
to communicate your ideas means that
it's not independent communication which
leads to the whole host of problems and
the reason that Asha came out with this
position
statement against it in in
there's over 200,000 members of
Asha and this is this is just it's well
researched we've got many well
researched and evidence-based methods to
assist
non-speakers this is not one of them you
know on their own website there's five
studies they're all by the same
person like I'm all for the use of funds
I just think this is an exclusionary
bill that excludes the use of that 400
4,5 00 for other Research b based
methods if you want to open it up to
here if you're a non-speaker with autism
and a pracy of speech and you apply for
a $4,500 Grant to further your AAC
something that's been done by a
professional that you're you need funds
for training then more power to
you um I appreciate your time hopefully
that answered your question represent Dr
you had your hand up or any further
you're good uh represent for did you
have your hand
up thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question I wonder about communication
and words that and ways that don't
depend on words because children can do
that M I have a three-year-old at home
it's not mine my
daughter's but she lives very much with
going to say
congratulations well she lives with me
in the same house and uh she walks up to
me and says may I kiss you you know and
you think she knows how to
communicate and so then you look at when
she gets frustrated she screams because
she doesn't have the word to say I'm a
I'm frustrated so
communication to an actor is a lot of
things and so I wonder when we focus
only on Words and don't get me wrong I
love words have a p PhD in English so I
love words but I spent a long time
playing with them I taught myself to
read MH and my problem when I got to
school was when they handed out the book
in the first grade I read it while they
were handing him out and so I wanted to
talk to the girl next to me about what
was in the book right and of course I
was
disruptive so and my colleagues will
attest to that so I think your question
is how much of communication is
non-verbal well it's about we've all
been talking about articulation as
communication but it's not all there is
to communication that is definitely true
much of communication is non-verbal and
most of what we say on a typical day not
today because we're here talking about
this but in your basic conversational
speech it's about 400 to 600 words make
up about 80% of of what people say so
words are not
everything thank you thank you very much
further
questions thank you very much for coming
thank you uh like to call back disil dis
pasquil Pali yeah pasquali yeah that's I
yeah you'll know I'm Italian in a
minute
chairman lad and members of the House
Education committee my name is Beth deep
pasquali and that is my adult daughter
Beth there Grace we live in Wilton I'm
asking you to support the house bill
1553 and creating a pilot project to
introduce spelling to communicate also
known as s2c into schools this project
is necessary for individuals who are
non-speakers minimal speak speakers or
unreliable speakers to live full
inclusive and productive lives for many
years I participated in traditional
speech therapy with the hopes that
someday I would have a meaningful
conversation with Grace and by
meaningful I
mean uh I'm talking about her telling me
what she wants to do with her life does
she think that Greek mythology is as
awesome as I do and what does she
believe in what is her spiritual path
meaningful as if saying more than just
mama I want a
snack for the last year and a half after
being introduced to s2c at an autism
conference I have been blessed to
experience those meaningful moments with
my daughter that's when I understood
that the reason my daughter was not
producing verbal output was due to her
araxia she knows what she wants to do or
say she just can't make her body do it I
also learned that by using a letter
board which uses gross motor movements
by poking letters instead of verbal
output which is a fine motor skill and
more difficult my daughter has gained
the skills to communicate what she wants
to know and what she wants to share I'll
be honest at first I was very skeptical
but once I started using it with my
daughter all that
changed recently grace spelled in her uh
to her s2c practitioner at a trading
session every time mom is spelling she
thinks she has to be perfect what you
have suggested is going to help
tremendously it's amazing the wisdom in
that statement she knew that I was
trying to be
perfect you see the premise that motor
planning differences could be at the
root of non-speakers communication
difficulties are just beginning to be
acknowledged however the research
supporting that claim has been acing for
some time when individuals with aaia are
taught the motor skills needed to
organize their body's gross motor
movements they can and do show their
intelligence in all the test that we
have to access cognition there is no
accommodations made for motor planning
difficulties all of these tests require
motor control and coordination of the
brain and body in order to show what
they know only after being given a
reliable communication method can
cognitive ability be accurately measured
spelling to communicate is that method
for my daughter and countless others
with
aaia passing this bill and allowing this
pilot project to move forward could be
the key to unlocking many doors for
those who are prisoners in their own
bodies thank you chairman lad and
members of the House of Education
committee for considering my testimony I
urge you to support hb1
1553 to create a pilot project for s2c
thank you very much uh you have written
testimony right there that you just read
from yes sir can you set submit it did
you make I submitted it online yesterday
but I would be happy to if you could
provide that to the clerk she can put
that right into the record sure we're
still paper pencil type stuff I love
that yeah okay there questions from the
committee
not see you thank you very much okay and
the last uh person that we have a card
from here is from Isadora
Rodriguez yeah and um you say you have
written testimony you didn't take a
position just want to speak to this bill
that's correct thank you good morning uh
Representatives um my name is isidora
Rodriguez legendre I'm the executive
director at the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities and we are
DED at to advocacy capacity building and
systems change work in New Hampshire
that helps remove barriers and create
opportunities for all individuals with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities we are neutral on this bill
however that being said that is
primarily because our membership drives
our work our members are people with
developmental disabilities parents
Guardians and agencies
um dedicated with similar uh missions in
supporting people with developmental
disabilities uh because of the
controversy and because of um some of
the testimony that you heard here today
our membership could not agree on a
position that being said one of the um
guiding oppositions to this bill is that
it's not an evidence-based
practice it's important to develop
evidence in order to determine whether
interventions are going to work and
pilot studies are a good way of doing
that um understanding that not every
intervention is going to work for every
individual that communication is very
personal and should be person centered
and um
self-determination uh should be
considered the primary f Focus having
someone be able to communicate
independently is the goal always um
so understanding that this
intervention is something that some
families or individuals may be willing
to explore and some may not um it's
important to
develop um an understanding about what
the potential is for this intervention
um within the autism and araxia
communities um I'm happy to take
questions I have written testimony uh
which kind of highlights some of the
points uh that I've
mentioned um again we're neutral on the
bill uh but we do believe that uh
removing barriers and creating
opportunities for individuals to
communicate is a
primary um need and support the ability
of individuals to explore those any
intervention that might help them do
that thank you very much are there
questions from the committee represent
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
your test uh testimony and expertise on
this um you brought up a point that um
autonomous communication is the goal
it's a very laudable goal um it's
certainly the
ideal I'm wondering is it possible at
least in a a Hy hypothetical context
that given our current abilities our
current knowledges and our current
practices there might be a portion of
the population that is not currently
going to become capable of fully
autonomous communication but might be
able to enjoy some degree of
communication through an
intermediary that's a great question and
I would not want to speculate on that
point
um however that being said there are
individuals with all kinds of
disabilities who depend on supporters on
Direct support professionals to be able
to eat shower go to work be
transported um and so ve very likely
this could
be another um skill set that someone may
need support
with further questions from the
committee
thank you very much thank you you're
welcome with that I'm going to close the
hearing down for
1553 and we will get ready here to move
into the next hearing which we have
scheduled for today is relative to
establishing a local education Freedom
account program which would be 1652 I
have to about make three PR calls to
doe and so would you just take this one
I it looks like we have Kevin doing this
and Mar pter wants to speak in Opp so so
far
yeah
ready for
you next next on our agenda for this
morning is House Bill
1652 relative to establishing a local
education Freedom account program and we
have the uh Prime sponsor representative
verbal thank
you now it's on yeah there we go uh good
morning uh honorable colleagues it's
like deja vu all over again um I assume
you all recognize this bill is we we had
some fairly robust discussions about
this uh a year ago and uh unfortunately
it was it was set upon the table and
it's something that I'm passionate
enough about that I'm coming back for
another bite of the apple and so since
we've already had a lot of discussions
about the workings of the
bill I'd like to tell tell you a little
story about
Deerfield uh to maybe persuade some of
you that have been uh reluctant to
support this bill to maybe change your
mind I'm going to talk about a bunch of
different schools I'm not saying one
school is better than the other I'm not
I'm not here to try to sift and sort but
I want to tell you a little
history over 20 years ago Deerfield had
almost Universal school
choice wherever you wanted to send your
kid Deerfield School District would
would pay the tuition to send your child
there and at the time New Hampshire had
rapidly increasing student
populations and that meant there were
fewer and fewer seats available in fewer
and fewer
schools and it became problematic for
Deerfield to
ensure every student had a had a spot
that would meet their
needs and so the solution 20 years ago
for that problem was to enter into an
exclusive almost exclusive contract with
conquered High School send they accept
they agreed to accept all of our
students for a 10-year span at um I
believe originally it was a 90%
minimum and that that worked okay he
guaranteed a spot for every kid and and
it it certainly you know met the the
bare minimum
needs after 10 years it was time for
Deerfield to re-evaluate our
situation we looked at several high
schools we had parent groups we had
teacher groups a school board did their
work and I think it's fairly well
recognized that the parents wanted to go
somewhere other than conquered and there
were other schools that could take all
of our
students the school board in its
Infinite Wisdom chose to renew a 10-year
contract with conquer largely driven by
the fact that conquered got uh very uh
competitive with its tuition rate
because it it knew it was it it was
potentially going to lose
students that 10-year contract second
10year
contract ends the end of June of this
year the 13-year exclusive cont contract
with conquered was proposed by the
school board and soundly defeated by the
voters of Deerfield voters of Deerfield
wanted school
choice an election was held a new
majority came in they did their
homework and what they did is they
negotiated with conquered high school
and a bunch of other schools where they
settled on was conquered High School
coob Brown Northwood Academy Academy and
pem Academy no minimums no maximums
varying tuition
rates and this year's eighth
graders more than
half chose coob
brown little less than half chose
conquered as far as I know last count
nobody chose Pembrook Academy for
whatever reason
right and so so that's what's going to
happen there was a small number of
students currently attending conquered
high school that have chosen to transfer
to co Brown next year now that that
option is
available those students those families
believe that Co Brown is a better fit
for their child's education and it's
fantastic that they have that
opportunity but wait it gets better
better we always say that we want all of
our kids
participating in the public education
system of New Hampshire right I think we
we all more or less agree on
that we have students coming out of
non-public school settings returning to
the Deerfield Public School System for
high school starting next
year so why would that be why would you
leave a private school why would you
leave home school why would you why
would you leave some other setting to
come back to the public school
system I guess first you have to ask why
did they leave in the first place they
left in the first place because the
school that was offered was not meeting
their needs and so they had to seek
something else
out and so now we have more options in
Deerfield and we have students returning
back to the public school system that's
a win-win that's a win for everybody in
my
opinion
right so is that the end all be for
Deerfield no I I don't I don't believe
it is I think there are probably
families sending uh students
to public school options in Deerfield
that would probably prefer something
else but they can't afford it or or the
school board didn't negotiate with that
board that other school so it makes it
difficult and so
what this bill
does is it allows a community by a super
majority vote to decide for themselves
if they want local education funding
money local tax money to be able to
follow the
student into a school that they believe
is a more appropriate
setting for their child for their
children I know we've had discussions
could be a runaway fiscal train it could
be right but it's enabled by a super
majority and it can be disabled by a
super majority so if a town chose to
enable if a school district my apologies
if a school district chose to enable
this and find out discovered later that
it was fiscally overburdensome they can
dis
discontinue the the project right and so
what it is is it takes State adequacy
multiplies it by two the bill um for a
community for a school district that
that adopts it the students that go
somewhere else that take the local EFA
would be counted for daily membership so
the state adequacy flows to the school
would then flow to the EFA and then a
matching amount for the same amount just
to make the math easy we we Peg it to
the adequacy grant can follow that
student that amount of
money is more than enough to allow the
vast majority of families to choose
virtually any education setting that
they want for their
children that is a win-win and if they
don't spend all of that money right if
they can educate their child four less
the money that that sits in that account
upon High School graduation or age of 21
goes back to the local school district
to offset taxes or or it basically goes
into the general funds or whatever the
the district chooses to to do with
it so
deerfield's an anecdote I get it right
one's an anecdote two is a coincidence
and three you can you can fit a line so
let's go to let's go to coincidence
level right we look at the state EFA
program and how wildly popular that is
because there's far more students
choosing to participate in that than uh
were originally projected so it's
wildely successful we know that there's
a need out there we know that that
parents want choices for their children
children this is a a nice local
control and and it could bring students
back into the public school system how
many of you have are in school districts
in declining
enrollment considering uh closing down
schools because you don't have the
students we're trying to find ways to
consolidate if you had a school that's
competitive and attractive
and you had a school district near you
that enabled this program you could draw
those students in right you could you
could actually grow your student
population because students will go to
the schools providing the services that
they need want and have to have and if
you see a decline in a school district
because of choice that should be very
telling to the school district L losing
students to other districts that maybe
it's it's time to re-evaluate the
product and services being provided to
better meet the needs of their actual
local constituents and maybe draw others
in and so I I would beg that uh the the
10 that voted uh in favor of ought to
pass for this bill hold strong and for
those of you that supported
itl I would ask you to give that some
thought give that some consideration and
would I would beg you I would implore
you to please support an a to pass so we
can get a majority a to pass on the
floor so we can at least have a robust
floor debate and and then uh see what
the the will of the body is thank you Mr
uh thank you
representative um representative Miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here this morning uh you had
indicated that the previous bill that
you presented was tabled uh does this
does 16 52 is it the same bill that was
tabled or have you made some
modifications to it it is the same Bill
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you R dry thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh in
the town of Cornish uh there's no high
school and when students reach high
school age they can go to any High
School of the surrounding areas uh for a
set tuition and the parents pay the
balance if this passes uh would that be
able to
continue or how would that change thank
you for the question that that's an
excellent question um so this bill would
not change that policy so if I
understand you correctly and please
correct me if I'm wrong um you're
tuition students to anywhere they want
to go under essentially a top off
agreement right so there's a a minimum
set amount because there's at least one
School uh that'll take all your kids at
that amount and if they want to go
somewhere more expensive if they make up
the difference right is that what you
doing yeah so that so Deerfield
considered that and we we chose not to
do top off agreement so we pay the
tuition of whatever the school is
currently that's our and these are
three-year contracts with these three
schools so no this bill would not change
that um and and so with essentially un
Universal school choice like that it's
hard to believe a community would choose
to adopt this because you already have
what this is enabling uh but you know
you never know till you ask the voters
right voters can decide for
themselves
representative
Woodcock good morning thank you for
being here um in your dialogue you
mentioned that U how much money was the
FY youngster or the student and then you
said that amount of money uh will be
enough and so I was trying to get to
figure how much is that amount of
money yeah that's an excellent question
and so um I'll refine my my remarks so I
think it goes to um similar to what uh
they're doing uh in in representative Dy
dr's District right
so there's a lot of working class middle
class Working Poor they they cannot
afford school choice period the end they
just don't have the cash for that we're
talking about approximately
$88,000 following a student um for a a
school district that would approve
this there are uh there are high schools
in New Hampshire that you can attend for
for about eight grand right um if you
choose a more expensive school then yes
it the burden would fall on the family
uh to make up that that difference right
because you're not forcing anybody to do
anything you're not forcing them to take
this up but if you make if you look at
the the the state EFA that
$4,000 has enabled a lot of families to
pursue other options that previously
they they they could not
do this increasing that amount um
significantly increases the the the
amount of students that potentially
could try something
differently Paul thank you so the figure
you're talking there is about $8,000
yeah State Ade so it's pegged adequacy
so as adequacy floats um the grant
floats right um there is a safety net
that a student's firste Grant sets a
minimum threshold So a family has a
safety net that they know it'll never be
less than that so they one year they
wouldn't be caught where all of a sudden
oh I got to I got a pitch in another
$1,000
$2,000 um so it sets a safety safety net
there so yeah it's Peg to adequacy right
now that's about eight grand thank you
thank you represent Tanner thank you
thank you for taking my question um I
noticed there's no fiscal note with this
and also I noticed that there's no it
has an FN but no l and one of the to
indicate the local
um fiscal uh Duty with this and I'm just
wondering if you could comment on why
there's no fiscal note and why there's
no local indicated in the um the chapter
Law chapter bill yeah thank you for the
question representative and and I have
to admit I'm I'm probably uh the least
qualified to answer um all of that
thoroughly uh what I will say is that
the uh office of legislative budget
assistant is unable to complete the
fiscal note for this bill so they're
trying uh as introduced as it's awaiting
uh information from the Department of
Education why the Department of
Education is is lagging on this I'm not
exactly uh I'm not exactly sure so I I
can't I can't answer that apparently it
is expected at uh at some point in the
future it is a local impact I don't I
don't
know I don't know how you would
calculate that so if I can I complete
the answer though just to let you know
so so I agree it's it should be FNL
right because it it goes to local monies
more than State monies because the
adequacy doesn't doesn't change just
where it
goes if everything I've been told about
my local public school is true and if
everything that I believe why families
prefer to choose local public rols is
correct then I would think the fiscal
impact would be uh incredibly limitate
uh limited uh because most students uh
prefer and families prefer their local
public school uh through grade eight
there's free
Transportation families of children want
their children to grow up and socialize
with neighborhood kids they want their
child to have a sense of community and
typically speaking the local public
school especially in a rural state like
New Hampshire the local public school uh
is much closer than anything else one of
the complaints of conquet of course for
us was the the travel time right from
from Deerfield to to conquered High um
is is considerable and so if you if you
have a thriving robust public school
that's meeting the the the needs and the
wants of students and families in the
community I would think a precious few
people would Avail themselves of a
program like this if it was enabled in
their
Community I would also confess that the
converse is true if you have um without
going into definition unless you want to
have that discussion if you have a
failing local public school if you have
a local public school that is not
providing the services and uh and the
product that that local families are
looking for um then yeah I can imagine a
program like this would be uh very very
appealing
and um so yeah I mean
that's quickly
please so um this is the second bite of
the Apple you've and maybe the third and
fourth as far as I'm concerned I've seen
it quite a bit so I'm wondering if if it
is the second bite of the Apple just
like the one that we had last time why
doesn't the education department and I
know you probably can't answer this but
it seems very odd that the educ ation
Department can't come up with a fiscal
note and that you can't get some idea of
what it's going to cost locally because
locally it's going to cost people money
they're going to have to give money into
the CFA and again there's little
accountability for that money and Co
Brown has a requirement of a certain
academic ability to get into Co Brown um
they have a test that the kids have to
take to get into Co Brown and there's
also schools that discriminate against
uh other kids so M the questions are
getting long I I'll answer every
question you have know why the
information is missing that's why I
don't I'm I'm wondering why the
information's missing yeah thank you so
to to take the first question I'm going
to stick with my original answer how do
you calculate what this costs if a local
District chooses to enable the program
how do you predict what it's going to
cost without knowing how many students
in that District would choose to Avail
them themselves right so I don't believe
that it can be calculated the cost
locally will be about $4,000 per student
which is typically far less than what a
local school uh invests in per in a per
pupil charge even if we use the state um
average spend per student per District
because they back a lot of spending out
right that to try to uniform the number
uh as to your allegations about how coob
Brown Northwood
Academy chooses to operate as a public
school I I have to admit we've had
robust discussions about this in
Deerfield and most of the accusations
that you are laying at their feet have
been laid bare coob Brown Northwood
Academy provides specialed services to
specialed students and fact for for a
deer field if a child is in special ed
there is an upcharge to cover those
charges cobr Northwood Academy is one of
the best academically performing schools
in this state and has been for decades
and it is a desirable school and they
receive students from Northwood and
straford and I think a few other
communities but Northwood and straford
that is the the school of record that is
the school they sent all their kids to
and if they didn't provide specialed
services to the level required by state
or federal law I'm pretty sure somebody
would have filed suit somewhere along
the way if you are from out of the
district say do uh well I don't know
maybe do send uh
Lancaster and you want to send your kid
to co coob Brown northw Academy yes
there is an application process because
there are only so many seats available
in that school and it can't be wide open
I think for business
reasons the deal that we have with
Deerfield is they will take any and all
students and meet any and all students
where they are and comply with with all
laws so cobr Northwood Academy is a
public Academy it's not a traditional um
public school so there are some
differences the fact that more than half
the eighth graders in Deerfield want to
go to coob Brown Northwood Academy over
conquered high school or pemrick Academy
tells me all I need to know about
accountability so we talk about account
accountability with the Statewide
assessment the Deerfield Community
School is below 50% proficient students
in English language arts mathematics and
science and has been for
years okay so I know my school is
underperforming in my opinion that's my
opinion but that's what the the the test
that we all agreed on the assessment we
agreed we would use they don't meet the
bar year after year and so where's the
accountability where is the mechanism
that forces them to do
better when children choose a school and
families choose to send their child
somewhere that's the accountability
because their choosing that they're not
forced into it by ZIP code by the
address in which they live but because
they want to go there so I would say
that that this has the accountability in
that it forces no one to go
anywhere but allows for freedom of
choice in
education I think I hit all your
questions and if I didn't I'd be more
than happy to to take them uh
individually thank you uh representative
um Bon quickly please we have three more
cards thank you Mr chair it is a very
brief question um why is it needed
couldn't any local District already put
this on the ballot as a
warrant thank you so thank you for the
questions I appreciate it so this is
local enabling
legislation um and I so deerfield's a
little funny right so we don't have a
high school of our own and so we have to
contract out for high school and so we
can either choose one size fits somebody
or school choice and we can decide on
the the size and scope of the school
choice my understanding is that if you
have a a high school uh to avoid to to
allow school choice like this I I
believe legislation is required to to
allow it uh further this is letting the
taxpayers it's letting the voters of a
school district uh decide their
self-determination if they want expanded
school choice in this this District
their District or not not the school
board uh not the executive board if it's
a if it's a you know larger District uh
you know an SAU comprised of other
districts um and so this is this is a
vehicle to to actually let the voters
and the taxpayers decide for themselves
how they'd like to proceed
forward thank you uh representative
Lakers I just have a really quick
technical question sure on um
page one line
27 it just says where the student or the
educator are both not physically present
and I'm just wondering if you meant that
to be one or the other or
both because with the or it's I don't
know grammatically confusing did you
mean student and educator are both or
did you mean for it to be one or the
other yeah it it's it's probably an
Andor um if one or both and and so um I
i' would be more than happy to work on a
friendly amendment to to correct that
and I appreciate you the the question
and bringing it to my attention thank
you rent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thanks uh very much for bringing this
forward again um by the department of
education's own numbers the the the vast
majority of students in the fa program
were already attending private schools
or in home schools they didn't um just
exit their um their their Public School
District but I was wondering in the um
in in your proposal here would the um
would the the local property taxpayers
in that District be responsible for
contributing that four five6 $7,000
which is the base plus the differentiate
to pay private school and um
homeschooling costs for kids already in
private and homeschool situations so
that's an excellent question um
so you have to be a member of the local
school district in order to uh qualify
for a local EFA if a district um was to
adopt this and so um just to go back to
deerfield's example for a minute right
there was some wailing and nashing of
teeth about increased educational
cost because of kids coming out of
private schools and home school to now
attend apparently coob Brown Northwood
Academy we don't know those numbers
exactly because of privacy reasons but
it's fairly safe to to assume but those
children have now come back into the
public education system right so that's
a
win-win so yes if a district was to
adopt this and uh let's say I had my
kids attending a private school
somewhere right I'm my kids are in
public school but if my kids were were
were in private school and I lived in
Deerfield and they they hadn't graduated
high school or hit 21 um yeah the year
after this comes into into play or the
year of I guess um I could notify my
local school district that I'm returning
my child to the to the local school
district taking them out of wherever
they were and putting them back in uh
and then Avail myself of the
EFA some people find that rather
problematic and and I I sense that you
do and and I don't don't I I find that
to be a joyous occasion and I guess it
comes down to what your perspective of
of public education is a lot of times
when people talk about public education
they're really referring to Public
Schools they talk about institutions not
students I believe public education is
the funding of a child's education using
public money a lot of districts force a
monopoly system based on home address to
the school that that allowed to be
attended so we we're making certain
families pay twice right so if I had if
I had my kids in private school I'd be
paying for my local public school first
I have to do that first that's my tax
bill legal obligation then if there's
money left over I can afford to send
them to private school right so I don't
I don't see the harm if a community
chooses right because we're not forcing
anybody if a community chooses to to
fund the education of all kids in their
Community out to high school age 21 uh I
I find that to be a win-win for for
families that in my view are are paying
twice but the short answer is yes
follow actually with the with the short
answer being being yes that that that
what what you're basically saying I just
want to confirm this that that um uh
family lives in Deerfield they they're
they've been sending their student to a
private school for years and years and
years no cost the Deerfield taxpayer
that with with if Deerfield were to
adopt these Provisions the Deerfield
taxpayers would be on the hook for five
six s $8,000 a year in those private
school tuition costs um well the only
place so on the whole I'll say yes your
your number estimates I don't agree with
because the state adequacy is is is
state but it also includes
differentiated Aid and it's both it
matches if if if that's yes thank you
certainly thank you for the question uh
see no further questions thank you very
much representative for uh uh being here
and bring this back thank you I
appreciate your time oh I'm sorry uh
this is the third time representative
Tanner the but the first model fiscally
uh didn't work out but this is the the
third
bite thank um uh The Honorable marjerie
Porter welcome
back
maybe um we can do the three minute um
time for the uh remaining uh people who
wish to
testify of course thank you Mr chair and
it's nice to see your faces again I'm
here in opposition to this bill um and I
have a couple of questions that I don't
think were adequately addressed by the
presentation we just
heard um the first thing is it says very
carefully in the bill that um people are
not allowed to get both the education
tax credit scholarship and an the EFA
scholarship local scholarship in the
same school year and my question
is that does that mean that somebody
could get the EFA scholarship from the
state and then get twice the EFA
scholarship from The Local District and
if that's the case the amount of money
that we're talking about is closer to
$155,000 rather than just the six or
seven we've been
discussing I'm also very concerned about
the vast Authority that the scholarship
organization has over everything in this
bill because the scholarship
organization is not answerable to the
voters in my community right now one of
our state reps is really hounding the
school district with with Freedom of
Information requests on all sorts of
expenses nickeling and diming them to
death if this bill were to pass and if
the taxpayer money was going to the
scholarship
organization we would have no control
there would be no Freedom of Information
acts that we
could the words not coming right we
couldn't ask them for information that
we can ask for our local school board
and local school
district it's giving up the authority
over our tax dollars to a private
organization and I find that
troubling
um there's part of the bill that says
that the uh EFA could not be reduced
from the first Year's amount so if the
first year the EFA is $10,000 but the
situation changes in the town and they
are no longer receiving the amount of
state A that they were in the past for
whatever reason the taxpayers of the
district are stuck paying that extra
because the person sending their kids to
private school would be guaranteed the
original figure no matter what the
school district did to cut their
costs It also says that differentiated
Aid would be added to the um base
adequacy
the question I have on that is what
happens if the child who has the
learning disability is miraculously
cured at this private school and no
longer needs the services are they going
to continue to get
the extra Aid that they would have
received from the state if they still
had the
disability if not then the state the
taxpayers are going to be paying for
that as
well as to the special education
services if a child's IEP it's says in
the bill that the local district is
required to take care of the special ed
needs of the child so if a kid needs a
one-on-one Aid and they're going to a
private school who hires that Aid who
evaluates
them your your time just went by done
three well I'm not done yet so I'm going
to ask you to please to please give me
minute we are on a timeline for
everybody honorable March Porter we've
got to move on here so you had three
minutes
uh are you open to questions we will
take your written testimony no it's not
written testimony thank you are there
questions from the from the
committee not yes represent
whitcock thank CH represent por could
you give me one point that you didn't
talk
about
please yeah thank you very much for that
question um twice in the New Hampshire
state constitution our assurances to me
as a tax beay that none of my tax
dollars would ever be used to support a
religious school or religious education
Twice first in the um Bill of Rights in
1787 and second later on in the late
1800s twice in in the Constitution I
have said that I have been promised that
my tax dollars would not go to pay for
Religious Education or religious schools
this program takes my tax dollars that
my husband and I struggle to pay our
property taxes every year takes my tax
dollars and sends it to the Christian
School up the road who teaches that the
Earth is 7,000 years old and I find that
difficult to accept thank you further
questions represent
Damon thank you for your testimony what
else would you like us to
know this bill is effective date of 60
days after
passage further questions from the
committee
luno so thank you very much Mr chair um
I'm I'm I'm guessing from what you said
that that your um your friends and
Neighbors in Hillsboro would not be very
excited about seeing their property
taxes go up to cover private school
tuition costs but but do you do you do
you you know do you think that may be
something similar in other you know
districts and towns across the state too
it would be and and one thing that's
troubling is that even if the town
decides to resend this program the
children who are already involved in
that continue to get the scholarship
until they graduate from high school so
if the town backs out if Hillsboro
decided to do this and then realize two
years later it wasn't going to work and
we sended it all of the children that
are already receiving those scholarships
would continue to receive those
scholarships until they graduate from
high school so if there's five kids
they're going to get their $10,000 or
whatever until until they graduate from
high school um that's a lot of money
thank you further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
Mr
chair I'd like to in invite uh Mr
Trumble
good
morning fine thank
you excuse me if you could press the
button thank you start over hi I'm David
FAL from the town of wear I oppose this
bill for a few reasons essentially I
think it's unconstitutional and it would
reduce funding for our local public
schools where 85% of our children go to
school the way I read it I think half
the money would come from the base
adequacy amount from the state's coffers
and the other half would would come from
the local school district each of those
I believe is unconstitutional this bill
basically says we're going to take the
money that's being spent on our local
public school and use it as an ATM
machine to fund any other educational
expense that it wants and there's
tuition materials computers and all
kinds of
things first of all just to go back the
state constitution says we have to fund
the public schools it doesn't say public
education it says public schools in the
Constitution The Claremont case said
that we have to Prov an education to
every public school all the children in
the public schools not the private
schools the US Constitution does not
require funding Public Schools I talked
about this last week chief judge
Robertson just last year said the state
need not subsidize private education the
reason is this private schools don't
have to follow public rules if you want
public money you should follow public
rules Mr veral talked about special ed
and the C Brown Academy I assume they
follow special ed rules but when you
sign up for an EFA you sign away all of
your rights to special education rules
all out the door and we know that in the
EFA program 6% of the children are
special ed compared to 20% in the public
schools look at any of the websites of
the private schools to get millions of
dollars under EFA look at their policy
for non-discrimination what word is
missing disability they do not have any
rights in that area now that 50% of the
money that comes from the state that was
by Statute from court cases that led to
commissions it led to the education
trust fund it led to the defining of the
word adequacy that's required money that
goes to the Local Schools this bill says
well that's a nice ATM I'll just use
that to fund kids going off to private
schools that's unconstitutional taking
of money from a constitutionally derived
fund where that money is to fulfill Our
obligation to have an adequate education
just because it's an educational expense
doesn't make it constitutional only the
Public School Educational expenses are
constitutional the other half of the
money comes from the local school
district and you say well that's local
money actually it's not local money The
Claremont 2 decision went back and
looked at the issue of the local
property tax so we in New Hampshire call
the local property tax and they said
this although the taxes levied by local
school districts are local in the sense
that they are levied upon property
within the district the taxes that are
in fact state taxes that have been
authorized by the legislature to the
fulfill the requirements of the New
Hampshire Constitution the taxes imposed
by the legislature for the support of
schools are in their nature state taxes
the state half of this funding is also a
state tax that was set up to fulfill our
constitutional obligation you can't take
that money and use it as an ATM to go
fund private schools it's
unconstitutional thank you very much are
there questions of Mr Trumble yes
represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much Mr Trumble again for your
testimony are you saying that um that
State dollars are being used to pay
tuition bills at schools that
discriminate against students with um
special
needs specic in reference to the efas
that is true the EFA program has no
requirement that a school that receives
that money follow the civil rights of
the state and specifically the one I
talked about was special ed when you
sign up for an EFA it's right on the
website where you sign up for it you
sign away a parent signs away their
rights under the federal special ed laws
so if you're not satisfied with that in
a public school you can complain you can
go to hearing you have a right to
special ed services in the private
schools in the EFA you have no rights
whatsoever to those Services thank you
represent cordelli do you have a
question uh yes um in terms of an EFA
student going to a a private school uh
um I'm not sure where they sign away any
rights um because don't they have the
ability to at any point return to that
private to the public school
and um reinstitute any services that
they're eligible for so I'm I'm not sure
where they're signing away any rights if
they attend the private school they have
to sign that they will not enforce their
federal education rights in that private
school setting
um maybe you could send me one of those
documents I'd Beed see I think it's
right on the the the state's website
where where the efas are set up it's
says you you you may not keep your
rights you know I've you never heard of
an EFA uh student having a full right to
um special ed services and if that
weren't the case why are there 20% in
the public schools and only 6% in the in
the in the private schools follow up yes
um in that case why are there 6% EFA
students going to a private school or
other educational options if they can't
get the services that they want for
their child thank you representative
cordelli that's a great question and I
think the reason is this last week we
had a hearing on special ed there was a
parent who came in and she said I have
two children who have special ed needs
one of them she said is very inexpensive
one of them is very expensive I don't
know if you remember that Mom who came
in and testified the inexpensive student
might only cost a couple thousand under
the EFA program you get the
differentiated Aid which is worth a
couple thousand so if that money
followed the student to the private
school that private school could afford
to pay those minimal services for that
student but any as this this moms words
expensive special ed child would only be
getting $2,000 to the private school if
it's uh remember the special ed hearing
from last week the average expenditure
for special ed students in on top is
$28,000 per student student if you're
only getting a
$2,000 bonus if you will in the private
school through the EFA program you don't
that it leaves you $26,000 short so
that's why you have so few special Edge
students in the private schools and I
would imagine just from P math I've seen
we SE no evidence because there's so
little data from the AFA program but
probably the the 6% are that Mom calls
her inexpensive child further questions
representative penell yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
should
we
um create a new statute under the EFA
program requiring that all special Aid
money follow special Aid students so now
they don't no longer have to wave their
rights I mean we could just shift that
money we could just add it to the EFA
program correct and then all special Aid
students could get all the special
Aid all of their special aid needs
fulfilled wherever they go thank you
representative pet so you're suggesting
that the EFA program would increase the
differentiated Aid portion going there
to cover 100% of the cost of special ed
okay and I think you know conceptually
that's fine but there's something that
has to happen before that you have three
bills in front of you to fully fund
special education in the public schools
those are the schools that under the
Constitution we have a constitutional
duty to spend the state has been
reluctant to fully fund special in the
public schools so once we do that in the
public schools then next year come back
and make that a bill and I would
probably support it but I can't see
doing that first and not fully funding
special ed in the public schools at the
state level does that make
sense okay represent
Tanner thank you do you know if um
private schools have to have to follow
the Americans with dis Disabilities Act
in other words do they have to have um
ramps if there's a child with a a
wheelchair bound or elevator or uh
special services like thatal I don't
know thank you representative Tanner I'm
not sure but I do know that I've done a
little research into the efas just to
look at the schools that are getting
funds and I've noticed the word
disability is absent in their statement
on non-discrimination but I don't know
the answer to whether the Ada applies
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to invite Deborah
house
okay good morning chairman lad members
of the committee my name is Deborah
house and I am here on behalf of
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire and our 3700 members across
the state uh to speak in opposition to
HB 1652 relative to establishing a local
Voucher Program uh we are opposed to
this because it would create a local
voucher program that could easily
decimate our local neighborhood Public
Schools as I have testified on several
different bills already the New
Hampshire Constitution places a duty on
the state to provide and fund a robust
public education system for all Granite
State children that would mean funding
local schools that in every District
across the state you can get individual
attention from a teacher support from
par Educators for your learning needs or
behavioral needs a school nurse a school
counselor to uh help you when you have
issues during the day until we have that
in every District across the state we
shouldn't be talking about any other
funding programs because that is
spending of Choice by the state or by
local governments so we need to take
care of those needs first this bill
would oblige local taxpayers to pick up
the tab for a second system of Education
based on families individual choices and
since there's only so much money you can
ring out of local property taxpayers who
support both the funding at the local
level and the state level with their
local property taxes or in Statewide
property taxes the creation of this
second system of Education would lead to
cutbacks in the constitutionally
required public education system and
those cutbacks come back and hurt our
students and I heard a previous
testifier talk about how the voucher
system is wildly popular there's about
5,000 students using the state vouchers
there's over 60,000 students using our
local neighborhood Public Schools so
you're talking about roughly
3% when you're comparing those numbers
we need to take care of the students
relying on our local neighborhood public
schools which is where most Grant State
families want their students to be able
to go to get a robust public education
and to be able to socialize with their
friends and Neighbors in their local
schools
um this local Voucher Program does not
have any limits on the income of the
families that can apply it means that
students who are already being
homeschooled or a p private school can
apply for a local voucher uh it means a
family that is struggling to meet their
bills and conquered would have to use
their property tax money to subsidize a
very well off family who wants to send
their children to St Paul's that's not
fair um he described this bill is
nothing by the Apple but remember the
Apple we're talking about is your local
property taxpayer who is already
overburdened because the state has not
fulfilled its constitutional duty to
adequately and fairly fund all our local
neighborhood District Public Schools
poll after poll is shown that families
across New Hampshire want to see the
legislature improve and invest in our
local neighborhood Public Schools so all
our kids can succeed and Thrive Grand
State families want quality stability
and
predictability which overall they get
from their public schools for all of
those reasons we urge you to find HB
16532 in expedient to legislate and I
thank you very much questions represent
dry yep thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming can I ask again where a
voucher program is in statute I'm
looking at the only one and it says
repealed is there a that you can use for
this that matches the
legislation it is government money that
is being used is tax money that is being
used to spend
for educational
choices that parents want to make if you
are redefining
it that is your choice to call it
something else but I am going to call it
what it is it's a voucher
further
questions representa cordelli thank you
um in terms of redefining things
couldn't we according to your theory
redefine pel grants as
vouchers chair is that to this bill well
seeing vouchers not in the bill I think
the whole conversation is not
relevant okay okay further questions
from the
committee thank you very
much all right so we have no further
pink cards on this one so we're closing
down 1652 and if members in the
committee want to stand up and stretch a
little bit right now we're going to be
starting this up again in a few moments
we have one bill before lunchtime here
so stretch it out a little bit if you
have
to I'll have to leave after this one
after the next one for the afternoon
I'll be here all day
Wednesday and Mark knows you got an
Escape Plan here
huh you know I'd rather
stay
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
last bill this morning that's HB
1691 this is relative to the definition
of an adequate education and I'd like to
welcome representative Glenn Celli to
the meeting
uh thank you very much Mr chairman and
honorable uh colleagues on the committee
uh for the record uh Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro wolfboro and oi
in the beautiful Lakes Region and um we
just heard uh a bill that was enabling
legislation um this bill I would term
statement
legislation um I can't tell you how many
times I've heard from constituents um
why can't we just concentrate on the
basics in our Public Schools well that's
the intent of this
bill it does not change the components
of an adequate education under um
statute it merely says that English
language arts reading math science and
social
studies should be the
emphasis and but we should still pay
attention to all the other areas that
are currently in statute such as fizzed
World languages Arts Finance personal
finance um it wants to make a statement
that schools need to emphasize the
basics and um if you look at our
proficiency scores I think that that
very well illustrates the need um about
15 minutes ago you each should have
received in your emails a spreadsheet uh
showing math uh proficiency levels and
English language arts proficiency levels
for every school in the state um it's
very
instructive um um yes no not yesterday
Friday seems like yesterday um we had a
a hearing on several uh funding bills
and um in in one in particular there was
new
spreadsheets um that went through the uh
the towns and the schools and uh how
they would Faire under the formula one
of the examples was Alton Alton would be
sending back money to the state um let
me just mention the proficiency rates in
Alton Alton Central School their
Elementary School math proficiency
25% English language arts
38% at their high school math is
27% and English language Arts
69% um I'll go to my own District
Governor Wentworth School
District English language arts
proficiency is
51% math proficiency is
43% and we are what is affectionately
termed a donor town or excess swept Town
um so we have a lot of room
um
and if you look at Tuftonboro is also
very similar um town to wolfboro in
terms of property values and so
forth these students go to the Kingswood
Regional Middle School Regional Middle
School seven communities tuen Boro
students 7eventh grade math
14% reading
33% if you look at the kids from
wolfboro who go to that same Middle
School 7th grade math is 40% and sth
grade reading is
39% um I I think this
illustrates the need um for concentrate
on the concentration on the basics I've
seen countless articles recently on um
businesses talking about trying to find
Qualified
employees um I've seen uh 40% 60% of
businesses saying they can't find
quality uh employees to
hire in that line let me read a a note I
got from the chairman of our Board of
Selectmen in
Tuftonboro in recent months I have
interviewed recent high school graduates
for entrylevel carpentry jobs none could
read a tape measure or divide a number
by two without using their
phone based on those two criteria I have
decided not to proceed any further with
interviews as the simple carpentry
techniques would be be far beyond their
level of
comprehension
um I I'm not going to uh prescribe well
in this bill anyway I'm not going to
prescribe um what has to be done to
improve those i' you know tried that I
tried that last year and um you know
we'll see what happens this year but um
I
think by stating that the emphasis has
to be placed on the
basics I think we can send a message um
to our New Hampshire schools but also to
our New Hampshire parents that we
recognize the problems that we face and
we are trying to take action by telling
the schools they've got to pay attention
to these subject areas because without
these subject areas um what does our
future
hold thank you thank you very much are
there any questions of Representative
cordelli representative Miler thank you
Mr chair and thank you for bringing this
forward uh isn't this bill the same bill
that was U that uh commissioner edel
blute brought before us two years ago
well I think it was actually um chairman
lad brought it forward a couple of years
ago and I I believe it is different from
that bill how is it different um all
those the current subject areas still
remain as part of adequacy all we're
doing is saying that emphasis should be
placed on the uh the top four the basics
a followup please yes so that would
still mean that the local school
district could determine exactly what
the curriculum should be correct uh
correct and how they would uh emphasize
those subjects thank
you further questions representa
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question could you put
Proficiency in um terms of the oldtime
ABCDEF um basis is it is it an a is it a
b is it a c d I think it's a different
measure along those lines there's cut
scores determined for uh the four
proficiency levels and that's what it's
based on and so what's under proficiency
what's the next level
down um
um um I'm I'm not sure how they're
termed it's 1 two three and four levels
three and four I know are proficiency
and uh above profession thank you
further questions from the committee
represent Ry thank you and thanks for
taking my question just humor me why
we're still saying beginning in the
school year 2008 8 2009 when it's
2024 I just um used current current
language from the statutes but uh we we
certainly could revise that
uh further questions represent
Woodcock thank you chairman just
represent thank you good morning good
morning just a question in your dialogue
you mentioned that um you're talking
about Al I'm assuming you're talking
about Prospect mountain when you're
talking about the high correct um you
tell those towns that that uh uh Fund in
that area and you said that the excess
swep money is donor money um so I want
to know where where is the excess SW
money donated
to um I didn't know we had donut towns
uh we we don't anymore um so that's not
true right excess sweat's not don't
right it was under the formula we were
looking at Friday that um they would uh
be sending money back to the state and
they um they do have excess swept now
and yes thank you but this kind of
Friday dialogue we really don't have
excess SW Don anywhere the people the
excess stays where it comes from is that
correct that is correct yes thank
you brother represent
Cornell I guess I'm confused does this
mean that you don't think that school
districts put the emphasis on English
math science and social studies in their
daily course
subjects uh I I think
that more has to be done to emphasize
those core core
subjects followup yes so what what do
you think they're doing because I spoke
to my school superintendent after one of
the other bills last week and she said
the emphasis in all Manchester schools
is on the Core Curriculum of English
math science and social studies and
they're fine they're they don't have to
do anything further to comply with this
bill who's going to Define it I'm
leaving that to the local level I'm not
going to prescribe you know additional
time requirements or anything like that
I'm leaving that to the local school
district thank
you are there further questions
represent cascaden um just a little bit
off of that question is there a
percentage of school that is not focused
on emphasizing the core program I I have
not done any surveys so we don't
know I I just I I know from the
proficiency levels um for all of our
schools that we have to do more um
they're um far short of even State
targets for proficiency levels
percentages are there further
questions yes repr
leus I just have a quick
clarification level one is below
proficient level two is approaching
proficient proficient three is
proficient and four is above
proficient further
questions uh thank you very much we have
other cards in this I'd like to invite
Deborah
house
welcome again yes thank you and just
checking around the Clare good morning
still uh my name is Deborah H and I'm
the president of the American Federation
of teachers New Hampshire here on behalf
of our 3700 teachers parent Educators
School support staff Public Service
employees and higher education staff to
oppose H
1691 uh we work with students about
30,000 of them across the state in many
districts um and they have a
constitutional right to a robust public
education this
bill the way it divides the um content
of an inadequate public education into
two
categories really seems to indicate that
one group is extremely important and
another group is less important and as
we know when you divide things like that
what's extreme important gets
funded what's less
important
is put to the side if you have time for
it if you have money for it and we
already know we don't have money to make
sure that all of our district schools
are funded fairly and equally in this
state so that every student in the state
has the same opportunity for robust
public education where they can get
individual attention from the teacher
learning support from a par educator uh
the ability to see a school nurse or a
counselor when they need it at school
all these things I've been testifying
about over and over again the past not
even 3 weeks um we must ensure that
every child has a complete and robust
and engaging curriculum that builds
their minds body and character all
public school students deserve to learn
in their neighborhood Public Schools the
academic content problem solving
critical thinking and teamwork skills
that will allow them to succeed in the
21st century economy AS Global Citizens
to do anything would be selling our
grand State citizens and their
communities
short so for this reason we are opposing
this bill because all of
those areas listed in the current
content of an adequate public education
were important enough for this body
to decide to adopt them and there's
nothing there that can be J in our
students need all of them but they also
need the funding so that they can be
adequately instructed in them and have
learning experiences Hands-On learning
with them when it's
appropriate and be able to engage in
them none of them are unimportant and we
shouldn't just be talking about
proficiency scores especially when we
can't Define them put a letter grade or
numeric uh percentage on them because
that's putting the cart well before the
horse if we're not funding all of our
schools so all of our students have the
same opportunity to learn and for those
reasons we oppose HB 1691 I do have
written testimony but I know it's a huge
typo in the heading so I will send it by
email after um thank you and uh that's
the end of my testimony thank you very
much represent petel thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my
question I'm just a little bit confused
by your presentation of this
um I've always operated with the
understanding when it comes to education
is that if you teach somebody to read
write and perform basic math they can
essentially if they wanted if they were
motivated could teach themselves
anything they wanted and essentially you
might not need a teacher if they were
highly motivated so if if you could you
possibly spend an entire first second
third fourth grade on PE is that have
the exact same equivalency of adequacy
as Reading Writing and basic math skills
do you know of any school where they're
spending an entire first second third
and fourth grade on PE that doesn't
strike me as anything that's happening
in any of our Public Schools certainly
not anything I know of so it should be
part of every student's public education
because it
is help health a healthy Habit to get
into it also helps sharpen the mind so
they are better able to learn when they
are doing their core academic subjects
it um is part of an adequate
education so dropping it would be
harmful to our students um and we should
not be giving our students a Bare Bones
education they deserve to have an art
education as well as learning how to
calculate how to you know read they they
should be able to read shakespare not
just read uh technical
manuals our citizens in New Hampshire
deserve a full robust public
education they have that
right
follow it's possible you and I might
agree on something
um when I hear the the word adequacy MH
to me it actually kind of equates
barebones education so maybe we need to
re maybe we need to
redefine
um what a basic education
is be because I I actually do find that
term
um uh kind of nebulous because Ade to me
adequacy adequate just adequate means
just enough to get along in the world so
do you think maybe we need to change the
term well the courts
have through their findings in the
various Claremont cases and subsequent
cases have um clarified that it is more
than just a barebones education so that
is where my understanding of adequate
being a robust education and that's why
I always refer to it as robust education
because um it is far more than just
Basics you know living skills are a
little bit more um that is not what
public education in New Hampshire is and
that is not what the constitutional
guarantee is uh it comes from the the
various Court
findings further questions rep represent
leus oh okay in the wrong direction I
understand that we need to look at money
I also understand that one of the things
that in life tends to be limited is time
and I know that students have limited
time that they can spend in the day so
my question is are you saying that all
things are equally important or should
we perhaps
prioritize some things over others when
we have limited time and we have to look
at it look at all of it that was qu I
had a second one as well but start with
that I don't think you need to be doing
that from this building thank
you was there a followup you ahead I had
a different question which is I was
wondering where it says that the lower
ones are not
important that is more a observation of
what the effect of of making two
categories like this we have seen how
that plays out thank you further
questions represent Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question um the
business Community uh has made some
different statements about what kind of
uh
education experience that they really
want uh in order for people to be
workers in a complex world uh economy
could
you could you just say some or do you
have any information on what they expect
and why some of these other um topics
that are taught in public school are
important among other things the
business Community wants
students to you know graduate being able
to work well with a team being able to
communicate clearly being able
to learn new skills
and uh domains because it is a fast
moving e economy what you train for now
may not even exist as a field in 5 years
or 10 years or a new field May grow that
you are um going to have
to um transition into because it is a
whole new category that Springs up so
they
need lifelong Learners who are able to
um work together and problem solve and
be nimble and be always always looking
for um ways to keep improving
themselves that's the Fe feedback that
that we've
heard further questions representative
Ford thank you thank you for taking my
question would you consider as you're
making these statements whether or not
we need to Define more carefully what it
means to be adequately educated in the
subject to which point I would point out
an example I worked as a carpenter one
day we were framing houses
and the boss told us to measure the
measure the frame and check it to see if
this uh Foundation area that we built
was square and one of the young
Carpenters said well how does that work
and so he quickly explained you know two
right triangles you put them together
and his expression and I'm going to
quote with one small
exception he explained you mean there
there's a use for that the vernacular is
a word I can't say but you understand
what I'm
saying and he clearly had learned about
triangles but he didn't learn how to use
triangles and so that my he didn't
understand that it was all part of an
understanding of things by
shape so that is experiential learning
that it would be wonderful if we had
more opportunities to give our students
that
Hands-On um practical
application of you how to use
knowledge to do things I mean that's a
use of geometry for instance um
and that is something that is actually
tied in with
um Competency Based learning when you
have the ability to plan for it at a
local level and coordinate it amongst
your departments and devise all sorts of
um wonderful experiences for students
to explore and apply what they're
learning it is really a great way to
reinforce and embed learning and do a
lot of cross-curricular work but it is
not something that can be done top down
or by a broad statement or or by trying
to Sho hornet in one size fits all
across the state it has to be done you
know either District by District or you
know in Cooperative districts up it it's
something that
is a wonderful way for students to learn
but it does
take a lot of professional time of
teachers and departments getting
together looking at what they're
teaching and how they can
um create experiences where students can
and be applying it and exploring with
with the knowledge so that next time
they come across a
situation they'll be able to use that
knowledge again or or come across a s
similar situation and apply it across
other situations
so it's Hands-On stuff and it just it it
takes you know a lot of time to kind of
figure out how to make that first
experience so then a student knows oh
okay here's how I can use it again and
again and
again and it's I guess I'm just a little
a former teacher y I'm a little skeptic
is there a question there sorry I got
talking pedagogy I apologize I I I think
where we're going is we're getting to we
can talk pedagogy another time that this
can be done on the side yep um are there
further
questions thank you very much yep and
the the last person we have is David
Trumble thank you Mr chairman I'm David
Trumble from the town
aware I appreciate that this bill wants
to send a message and find ways to
improve our schools I think everybody in
this room does I don't think this is the
right way to do it though if you have a
limited amount of money and you start
spending more time on one thing you're
going to have to decrease time for
something else so you say well what else
could we do we could spend more money we
know that we're underfunding public
schools by $550 million that was the
clear conclusion of the conval case what
would that look like more reading
specialists in our elementary schools so
that young kids get that attention they
need so they can read and as the
question said once you learn how to read
then you can do lots of other things
smaller classroom sizes if you've ever
been in elementary school or worked with
little kids 30 or 35 all day long is a
lot 20 or 25 is a lot better that
requires more money we can get
representative cordell's objectives met
but not by deemphasizing the other seven
but rather by putting more resources in
so that everybody can do it and the
question came up about Manchester
they're already doing this bill
apparently but are there proficiency
scores the model that we're going to
have for the state is that the new bar I
don't know let's look at these 11
learning areas they are written in law
as a result of the London Dair case said
you got to Define adequacy it came back
and there was a by Camal House and
Senate bipartisan group came out of this
committee either unanimous or 19 to1 and
went sailing through because everybody
agreed these 11 areas were important
that was agreed upon by everyone the New
Hampshire Constitution is not just the
basics the con Claremont 2 case
specifically mentions beyond the basics
the social economics scientific
technological and political realities of
today knowledge of mental and physical
wellness grounding in the Arts cultural
and historical Heritage and academic and
Vocational skills it's constitutionally
required that all 11 of these areas be
funded and properly educated why is that
because a lot of these areas are all
interrelated there was a study of over a
thousand middle school students that
studied the impact of music education on
math and reading Professor burgie from
the University Kansas School music
wrotes this therefore if your school's
goal rather is to educate the person to
develop the person's mind then you need
to educate the whole person in other
words learning may not be as modular as
it is often thought to be music makes
reading and math better if you cut the
music programs Dow goes your reading and
math scores another thing this Cuts is
computer skills the Federal Reserve Bank
of Atlanta did a study of 40 million
jobs and determin that over 92% of jobs
require digital skills if we're cutting
computer based based education under
this bill or attention to it or time
spent on it we're going to have students
who aren't prepared for the future art
is critical to self-expression it may be
that one class that gets in student
inspired to be in school for the whole
day world languages are key to
understanding people all over the world
and being able to communicate with
people all over the world physical
education it's key to your well your
personal Wellness but it's also a place
where we take the emphasis also off of
winning and put it onto access and
making everybody be welcome fed teaches
important values that need to be taught
as well we can't solve this problem by
taking a small pie and making it smaller
for a lots of other skills the solution
we all know it I think I maybe we don't
I think is to make the P bigger so we
can have better class sizes more reading
specialist then we can meet the goal of
this bill without cutting these other
seven essential learning areas thank you
for your time thank you very much
represent
leas do you think that we
could
emphasize English Math Science Social
Studies while teaching Arts World
languages physical education
Etc I think they're all interrelated yes
so how is this bill cutting those things
okay what this is the problem I have
with the bill is is in the language let
me go to the bill it it's says right now
the current okay the current bill just
has the initial language that says all
11 of these are what it means to have
adequacy and we must meet all 11 the the
new bill says that we're going to put
emphasis on four and then for the second
group of 11 it says with attention to so
there is no definition of what attention
to means if a school says well we're
going to cut fizzed and we're going to
cut financial literacy and computer
training and art uh and World Language
is by 50% we're still giving it
attention so that would be legally
acceptable under this bill and I think
that without additional resources if
you're going to spend more time on the
basics the the the four at the beginning
you're going to have to take time away
so either you take time away from these
other seven or you put more money into
the system so you have smaller class
sizes more reading Specialists then we
can meet the goal of emphasizing these
first four without taking it out of the
other seven
I got a question for you yes Mr chairman
if we're looking at numbers one two
three and four are subject content areas
there do you think by doing this that
there's going to be any more attention
given to science and social studies due
to the fact we only have a Statewide
assessment for the top
two um is the Statewide assessment part
of our issue here that we have that
driving the ship that's what people are
held accountable for that's what we look
at achievement and based that on and
growth on we had
testimony last
year from um from
Nea that there's a problem we have with
Civics education and social studies
there's a lack of that in our schools
today so by doing this are we going to
see any improvements if we don't a
absolutely look at how we're assessing
and where we are putting the emphasis in
terms of our accountabil
thank you Mr chairman that's a great
question um I I do agree we only test I
think those two areas so that's the only
area that you can have some data from
that gives you longitudinal you know
over the years but as people point out
the the proficiency standard is an
arbitrary one that's doesn't isn't
really set in stone I I think all of
these 11 areas I'm not against spending
time on the top four I'm saying if you
got a teacher who's got 35 children in
their class classroom it's really hard
to help Johnny who's having a hard time
reading if you got 34 other children if
you can have a reading Specialist or
smaller class sizes those children are
going to learn the basics better and
then we can have all of the education
every subject gets better but but saying
we're going to spend less time on these
other seven I think would be to the
detriment of the children oh don't
misunderstand me I'm not trying to say
that I I understand that um if I asked
an elementary kid their favorite course
they're going to say
recess and that's
number not even a number um so no recess
is not physical education physical
education they come in and they have I
understand that I have a PE teacher as a
wife okay it's a valuable it's a really
valuable part of the day of Education I
just don't think we should be cutting
these other seven or deemphasizing them
or saying just attention is good enough
I I think we should go back to what this
committee did when they wrote the
adequacy law stick with all 11 they're
all important and if we're not happy
with the big four spend more money on
our schools smaller class sizes more
reading Specialists that's a better way
to solve the problems that were
identified at the beginning of this
hearing I'd have a comment it's not a
question though but I I I I will say it
do you think
that we
are we have these 11 areas is that I
consider part of an adequate education
which I also feel they all need
emphasis um do you think
by do you think which Weir that well I I
guess I I'm trying to address the issue
of our music our theater programs our
art programs and many parents send their
kids to schools like we do when we
tuition our high school kids out of
pymont they choose Oxo across the the
river in Bradford Vermont because of
their theater program and because of
their athletic
program
so so I guess in what I'm trying to
saying um would you believe that I
believe that all 11 of these are just as
important you think are you saying do I
believe all 11 are equally important
well do you believe that I believe do I
believe that you believe other words do
I make my point I I'll go with that yes
sir yeah
thank you very much any further
questions this concludes we have no more
cards so it's lunchtime we will close
this hearing and come back at the
prescribed time which
is
12:45 and this afternoon we got bills
coming up on Cooperative schools that'll
be an exciting group of bills and only
there's
different
e
I was walking over here to
moast sorry
you he's got them all
yeah you them right
now you can give them all to us
right
thank
[Music]
you
okay if there's any committee members
here do not get the bill or the uh uh
testimony that was handed to us on the
epip pin it's back on the back table
right now if you did not get a
copy from the MD
people yeah
yep okay so what we're going to do right
now we're going to jump right into 1493
this is a bill relative to the powers
and duties of the Cooperative School
District budget committees we've been
there and done this before and we're
going to do it again uh representative
spillsbury
welcome thank you Mr
chairman well
I think if we didn't regularly have a
rotation of new Representatives you know
who don't know past
history we'd lose a lot of the drama
um thank you Mr chairman and members uh
I've been a a guest of the education
committee the last two weeks and I hope
I don't overextend my welcome this
afternoon because I'm going to come up
on four bills well it's interesting note
your bill has a little over 10 lines in
it of which you've asked for 10 minutes
well I think I can probably do this the
way we work is the prime sponsor as much
time as they need you don't I'm leaving
time for
questions the bill is very simple the
current statute to
1952a says that the Cooperative school
budget committee shall have the powers
and duties of Municipal budget committee
under RSA
32 in so far as the budget for the
Cooperative school district is
concerned now that sounds fairly
sweeping to me and I think if you read
it casually you would assume that it's
it's therefore implied that absolutely
everything having to do with
spending but as it turns
out school districts are being Guided by
their Municipal attorneys that that
means that the school budget committee
only has to be involved with the
formation of the budget
itself so my Amendment adds a new
sentence Additionally the committee
shall review and evaluate any warrant
articles or supplemental Appropriations
involving the expenditure of funds not
previously authorized no warrant
articles shall be printed on the annual
town meeting Ballot or special meeting
ballot without approval by the
committee I hope this is
noncontroversial
the essence of it is to say that
any um motion
special appropriation warant article
that involves spending funds that are
not previously authorized would have to
go through the budget committee and the
budget committee would have to evaluate
it express their opinion and that that
would then be disclosed when the warrant
was being considered by the
voters um I would have thought as I said
that that an amendment like this
wouldn't be needed but I've listened to
the um opinions of Council to Fall
Mountain I won't mention his name but he
is highly regarded as arguably the
foremost Municipal attorney in the state
practicing with the
districts um and his guidance
is nope warrant articles special
spending measures
supplementals the question that came up
in the
fall was how will the funds be used that
were the result of the increases to
adequacy Aid authorized by the
legislature in June in
hb2 and at the public hearing I was
offered the opportunity for the first
question and I held back on any
commentary about what was being proposed
what was being proposed was to take the
bulk of the funds and uh PVE repay the
parking lot and driveway at the high
school my question was where does the
budget committee stand on
this and I was told the budget committee
hasn't been consulted and I asked why
and that's when we got the opinion and
then backed up by the opinion of the
council that the statute didn't require
it now as a very technical matter I
forget the citation but it's in
195 I went back that evening and read
the statute very
closely and I then wrote a memo to the
school district arguing that in fact
even for those kinds of
supplementals um the budget committee
does you can't bypass the budget
committee but it's an ambiguous area of
law it doesn't make it absolutely clear
it doesn't make it clear that it
involves other
situations than the kind that
occurs when the state legislature sets
the state budget after the district
budgets have been set in
March and so um I I'm willing to take
any questions this is just simply a good
governance uh measure in a district
where the voters have adopted a formal
budget committee that budget Committee
in my opinion needs to be involved in
every new spending
matter thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
representative
Luna thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much representative spillsbury
for joining us this afternoon
um uh in my uh in my you know 12 years
on the Hopkinson School Board um
obviously we had a number of um worn
articles and and um with respect to
capital reserve funds uh uh some more in
articles that actually created capital
reserve funds and so my question
is when a um when a capital reserve fund
is created by the voters um at the uh
you know at the school district or at
the town meeting um you know on a on a
on a warrant article and the capital
reserve fund gives let's say the school
board sole authority to expend uh monies
from this fund given deposits from that
fund are still subject to to approval by
the budget or recommendation by the
budget committee and and a vote on the
warrant but talking about expending from
the capital reserve fund would would
would this proposal run you know
essentially conflict with um with
existing um voter approved uh capital
reserve
funds so let me make sure that I
understand the distinctions you are
making um I'm very familiar that with
with the kind of Warrant articles you're
talking about and it typically Fall
Mountain would have warrant articles to
expend from existing reserves town by
Town typically five plus a sixth one for
the high school and then they would have
another W article that gets to the
question of whether any surplus funds
might be deposited to the I would I
would contend that every one of those
should be reviewed by the budget
committee so that the budget committee
can register its opinion before the
voters are called upon to to
vote but that doesn't you know once a
warrant article has been approved
uh to take $35,000 out of the such and
such U Reserve fund for you know secure
entrance then it wouldn't require
reapprovals go ahead um so my my
question though is if a uh if a school
district um uh such as Fall Mountain had
a capital reserve fund for you know
facilities and maintenance or something
like that um that was and and that fun F
was created years before at a um at a
you know at a school district meeting
and that fund was created was you know
on the on the warrant and the
description of that fund gave the school
board um sole discretion for expending
from the
fund would would would this language
here conflict with that because now it's
saying that the school board does not
have sole discretion that it would um
still have to go to the budget committee
for approval
first okay you're raising a question I
hadn't contemplated I'm not aware that
there are uh warrant articles worded in
the way that you said but I would say it
overrides that that certainly would be
my intention in other words fact that
there's
$300,000 currently held in reserve isn't
the question of the warrant article
you're describing the question is
whether the 35 $5,000 will be taken out
for a given purpose right and I would
say that we need to make sure the budget
committee is part of the evaluation and
that their opinion is expressed and made
known to the voters before the voters
make an informed
decision represent
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm on both the
school Municipal budget committee and
our work basically is from the fall up
until the time the budgets are said in
January February early February and
after that we aren't involved in the
expenditure process until the following
year because we're a budget committee
we're not
a a legislative oversight committee or
whatever you want to say we're not
like um Vice school board or vice M you
know Selectmen we don't tell the
Selectmen I mean they have they have
capital reserve funds that are for fire
engines that sort of thing and and um
but the school often has Capital funds
for facilities and and they'll have a
capital reserve for special education
it's more it's not as specific as the
municipal one is
um does your in this bill do you expect
that the budget committee will
be involved in in all the decisions
throughout the whole year no no it's not
the purpose of the bill to
involve um the budget Committee in
actual
spending it's the authorization of
spending it's the appropriation process
it's it's what occurs leading up to any
decision that the voters would have to
make right so we know that that's at the
least an annual budget cycle with a
February deliberative if you're SP2 town
and uh March ballot but the point of the
bill is to make sure that that
also is uh enforc his to Warrant
articles and supplemental Appropriations
a supplemental appropriation is entirely
different than how the money is then um
administered and spent once the
appropriation has has
occurred yes so you know we're on suvin
County um and we actually come in and as
the representatives and do what you're I
think what you're uh proposing that we
come in sometimes for the Commissioners
if they're making an expenditure that we
we kind of approve and but there's a
bottom to it so it isn't like we're in
they want to spend you know $200 on
something uh a new curtain in a uh a
classroom or something or um you know
with the with the county with we have a
certain level and I don't see any level
in this bill where it seems like uh you
know you would say expenditures over
20,000 or over 50,000 something like
that but you know you're talking uh what
were you talking $33,500 for a parking
lot that that you want to get down to
that granular level is that your
intent
no I don't think you and I
representative Tanner are saying
anything differently we just need to to
find the distinction between what we're
saying we're not in Conflict I don't
believe uh the parking lot proposal by
the way was a couple
$100,000 so again once monies have been
authorized through the adoption of a
budget through the adoption of a warrant
article or through the adoption of a
supplemental
appropriation that role of the budget
committee is done as to that expenditure
so you're talking about how does an
expenditure get made
after uh an amount is authorized but you
and I have sat together on the Sullivan
County EFC and uh it's the same sort of
process the the EFC and the delegation
gets
involved in the
budget the authorization of how arpa
funds would be
spent um the question of bond issues and
authorizing but once the authorization
decision has been made the delegation is
to the Commissioners in the
administration the same thing that I'm
talking about here once the
authorization decision has been made the
voters have spoken then beyond that
point is what you're describing and
beyond that point is what this bill does
not
reach further questions represent
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question this is
a Sullivan County discussion
apparently um I just wanted to inquire
so this bill is specific to Cooperative
School District budget committees is
there statute that uh is similar to this
for other School District budget
committees that aren't
Cooperative well I'm going to defer to
The Experts here but my understanding of
the law is that where there is a school
district entirely within uh the
geographic confines of a particular
municip ality then it's
3214 that governs the creation of a
municipal budget committee and includes
authority to deal with the school budget
through the same entity it's only when
you get to a Cooperative School District
that you then refer to RSA
195 and there's sort of a confusing link
between 3214 and 195 but uh um so that's
why I've addressed Cooperative school
districts I've also found
I have some bills before Municipal and
County and we get into this thing here
in the legislature where uh bills
relating to the municipal governance are
delegated to one committee and those
that relate to the schools and other and
then every once in a while we look at
the intersection we're a little
unsure further
questions yes represent
bbon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um my question
pertains to line nine on your bill where
it says no warrant article shall be
printed on the annual town meeting
Ballot or special meeting ballot without
approval by the committee um I'm
confused by that does that mean that the
committee has to approve of the warrant
article before it's even printed because
I know in my budget there's a space
where it says you know the town budget
committee um approves this or or or
doesn't um so sometimes the budget
committee doesn't approve it but it
still is printed on the
ballot yeah I think that's a very good
question um that sentence is a product
of my work with
OS and I think it could be
improved
um I think that
uh my intention wasn't that the budget
committee could stop something from
going to the voters but rather that the
budget committee had to be
consulted had to have an opportunity for
Meaningful um
consideration and then would express its
opinion and in fact I believe when I
sent my uh LSR
request I stipulated that the vote of
the budget committee would be printed on
the warrant and I I I actually think
that that would be u a worthwhile thing
to add so perhaps the question you're
asking should be
clarified and in the same course perhaps
you'd consider putting in the
stipulation that the um determination
the vote of the budget committee is
[Music]
disclosed is it
there yeah it
is
yeah I further
questions thank you very much thank
you uh we'll have be
Christina thank you chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee
Barrett Christina from the school boards
Association uh we are opposed to uh
House Bill
1493 um a couple aspects um in existing
law that I want to hopefully provide
some clarification for the uh for the
committee um relative to the the the
budget committee's um
authorization um we know that RSA
195 12a the budget committee this is
paragraph 2 says the Cooperative School
District budget committee shall have the
powers and duties of the municipal
budget committee under the provisions of
RSA 32 in so far as the budget for the
Cooperative school district is concerned
and in so far as RSA 32 is applicable to
The Cooperative School District budget
so that statute about the budget the
bill brings other sorts of expenditure
special warrant articles expenditures
from capital reserve funds so on and so
forth I'll come back to that in a minute
as well too but we know that excuse me
um Cooperative School District budget
committees operate similarly to as they
do under Municipal budget committees
under RSA 32 RSA 32 colon 16 the duties
and authority of the budget
Committee in any town which has adopted
the provisions of the subdivision that
also means School District as well too
the budget committee shall have the
following duties and responsibilities to
prepare the budget as prepared in RSA 32
col 5 um and if authorized under s SP2
default budget for submission to each
annual or special meeting of the voters
of the municipality so under RSA 32 the
budget committee's responsibility is
limited to the budget your operating
budget which we know goes on warrant as
a separate warrant article it's separate
from a a special warrant article if
you're trying to raise an appropriate
$200,000 to do the roof for the the
parking lot or whatever it might be um
we also have another bill um that was in
Municipal and County house bill I
believe it's 11:05 which is looking to
clarify the definition of the budget but
RSA 32 colon 3 has a very specific
definition of what the budget is so we
know that under 32 both the mun both the
bucom statute tying it back to the
definition of the budget the budget
committee's responsibility is only the
budget relative to um the comments um
that um the representative made um about
the bucom um sort of reviewing this or
making making a notation of whether or
not they support the expenditure or
don't don't support the expenditure this
is RSA 32 colon 5 paragraph
5 when any when any purpose of
appropriation submitted by the governing
body or by petition appear in the
warrant as part of a special warrant
article the article shall contain a
notation of whether or not the
appropriation is recommended by the
governing body and if there is a budget
committee a notation of whether or not
it is not recommended by the budget
committee so the the the withdrawal from
the capital reserve fund is kind of a
different animal but if you have a a
budget committee if your community in
your school district has adopted a
municipal budget committee the budget
committee doesn't prepare the special
warrant articles but they're still
giving an notation to the voters of
whether or not the bucom supports or
does not support raising money for that
particular purpose so um I I don't think
that the bills is necessary I think some
of the things that the prime sponsor
spoke about the budget committee already
has authority to do and terms of putting
their notation on on the article whether
or not the budget committee supports it
or doesn't support it we would um
significantly object to the to the
provision specifically about the bill
about having to get budget committee
Authority um to withdraw money from the
capital reserve fund um this is RSA 35
col 15 and representative luno you
talked about it that often times the the
school board or the or the select board
is name sort of Trustee of the of the
trust funds and is given given authority
to expend that money depending on how
the language of the create of the of the
trust was created and the warrant
article was was worded whenever 30 years
ago whenever that may have been but it
says persons holding uh said capital
reserve funds and Trust as provided in
this chapter shall hold the same until
such time as the town District or County
shall have voted to withdraw funds from
the capital reserve fund so the
authority to withdraw is is to some
degree already put in the hands of the
voters when they've determined whether
or not it's going to be the school board
or the trustee of the trust funds or
whoever the voters have decided is given
um authority to um to expend from that
trust fund um I guess the other aspect
from a sort of a practical aspect um you
know the budget committee is looking at
sort of future expenditures if you will
next year's budget next year's
Appropriations the capital reserve fund
that money has already been appropriated
the voters have already have already
appropriated that and put it in this
place as a a savings account if you will
for special ed cost Transportation cost
tuition cost facilities cost whatever it
might be so the voters have already
authorized that money being expended
it's just sitting in again essentially a
savings account right now until the
school board or whoever is given
authorization to expend determines that
yeah we need the roof or we need to buy
a bus or whatever it might be so um I
think those uh conclude uh nhs's uh
testimony I'm happy to happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have so if the um Co-op has a Special
Reserve account for catastrophic Aid and
you have small small district and all of
a sudden you have this huge you know
costing Factor come in with a student
which happens
yep what would be the steps for getting
that money out of that account yes so
thank you very much representative I'll
be honest with you I I was digging
through RSA 35 over the weekend um to um
to to sort of prep myself and and and
review I haven't looked at the statute
in a while um but often times as I
believe representative luno referred to
when the trust is created you can put
Lang and it's created via warrant
article the voters have to have to vote
on and it's not just like it it just
appears the voters are approving this I
believe there's language in usually in
in in the warrant article that gives the
School Board specific authority to
expend that money when the school board
deems it necessary and there are
certainly reporting requirements coming
out you know it has to be I believe it
has to be included in the annual report
the school board is obviously going to
discuss that at a public meeting so it's
not like it's being done in the dark or
or in any non-transparent manner it's
going to be full and open process for
the school board to determine whether or
not they want to withdraw that money
from the reserve fund for again whatever
purpose the school board deems deems is
necessary under the the constraints of
the trust and how the trust is worded
thank you further
questions not see any further questions
on this thank you very much thank you
very much
y you
might represent Pillsbury spillsbury I
mean do you do you have your hand
up just one very time sure go
ahead
I think much of the discussion has been
a red hering it's off Target what this
line what the Bill's Amendment language
says is warrant articles or supplemental
Appropriations involving the expenditure
of funds not
previously authorized so we're only
talking about the process that leads to
the authorization not the process of how
money is spent after the
authorization thank
you
not seeing any pink cards other pink
cards on 1493 we'll close this hearing
and we will go into the next one which
is
1642 relative to the role of the Cooper
School District Board member
Representatives on a School District
budget committee and once again uh
welcoming representative spillsbury
thank you again Mr
chairman well this is very efficiently
scheduled one after another thank you
for that uh this is an extremely simple
Bill current law says that there will be
a ex officio member of the budg of the
Cooperative School District's budget
committee from the school
board with all powers and duties of any
other member of the committee which of
course includes the right to
vote so the bill simply changes the
school board members participation to
that of an ex oficio non- voting
capacity so
why it's very
interesting in Fall Mountain again to
use the example that's home to
me we have five towns each pre-existing
district has a
representative there are a school board
member there are two at Large and so
there's a total of seven and uh many
votes are decided on 43 basis an odd
number I think is pretty much the scheme
in every school
board but the budget committee statute
says that the budget committee will be
comprised in the same fashion as the
school board so it likewise gets seven
members five from the pre-existing
districts two at Large
and then we go and we put an eighth on
it so my question to the to the
education committee is why are we
designating one member of the school
board which is making its own
independent decisions and voting uh why
are we putting one of their members onto
the budget
committee um taking the budget committee
out of having the same composition and
balance as the school
board and waiting it in that fashion
think it's
illogical and I've watched it play out
in ways that I think are unfortunate so
in the tender
balance um of interests that I see in
Fall Mountain I suspect that uh this is
probably playing out weirdly and other
districts as well very simple
Bill School Board still designates
somebody School Board still has a rep
there's still communication and
understanding passing between the two
bodies but it's a non- voting
position so I got a question for you the
if you're on a local uh uh select
board and the select board can appoint a
member from that board to the zoning
board who is a voting member why should
that not be able to occur then here in
this situation it's an interesting
distinction um the statutes on planning
boards describe six elected members
and the seventh member as statute
requires is an ex official voting member
from the select board so that's a
distinct
statute sets up a distinct
scheme ends up with a odd
number and U it makes sense to me but uh
here where the statute says
the The Cooperative School District
budget committee shall have the same
composition as the school boards we then
end up knocking it off of
that further questions from the
committee oh represent B Bon thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question U my question has to do with
you you mentioned that this is your
particular Cooperative district and you
thought that um other districts might
have the same sort of issue that you're
having I'm wondering if you could name
any of
those no I'm not here in a position to
speak about other
districts thank
you further
questions thank you very much wait
minute is there somebody at rson Hall do
you have your hand
up okay thank you very
much bar
Christina
thank you again chairman lad hello again
members of the committee baric Christina
from the school Wars Association we are
opposed to House Bill uh
1642 um I understand um the prime
sponsor's um concern with you end up
with an even number of of committees on
the uh on the on on the co-op budget
committee because you have an odd number
of school board members which is a
statutory requirement that you have an
odd number rather than um making the
school board member and ex officio nonv
voting member of the committee um we
think that maybe an amendment to the um
preceding language on lines four and
five where it says the budget committee
this is current law the bucom shall have
the same number of members as the
Cooperative School District plus the
Schoolboard member that makes an even
number change that language and just say
that the bucom shall have an even number
of of of members um plus the the the
school board voting member would make an
odd number so we're not going to run
into a tie or whatnot I guess the other
issue that nsba would have is um um uh
you know if if the if the budget
committee if the budget committee is
that split and it's going to be a 44
Vote or a 55 Vote or whatever it is and
that tells me that one the School Board
needs to perhaps do a better job kind of
explaining its rationale for presenting
its budget to the school to the to the
budget committee but also the members of
that budget committee have to sort of
maybe work to reach some sort of
compromise on either what the bottom
line is or what specific you know
Appropriations are going to be made or
what line items are going to be adjusted
within within that budget um you know we
don't think that taking way sort of the
voting voice of the of the school board
member on the Cooperative school
district is is the best way to address
some of the the challenges that that may
have been raised in at least at least
one Cooperative School District so uh
for those reasons NH o nsba opposes the
bill I'm happy to answer any
questions are there any questions yes
represent
leus I'm wondering what why you're
wanting to give a school board member
two voices two
votes um rather than one vote on the
school board and then the budget
committee has their votes and they're
separate it makes sense to have
the have a member of the school board
there for asking questions and all of
that kind of stuff but
um why do you think they should have two
votes as opposed to the budget
committee their vote and it's sure thank
you for the question represent that's
certainly a fair question um I guess I
would say while they're getting two
votes they're on two different just very
distinct public bodies the budget
committee is a separate public body than
the school board is people can't serve
on both per statute but people can
certainly serve on more than one public
body plenty of people in this in this
building are on select board and and and
school boards and whatnot there are
people that are both on a select board
um and and a school board um so I guess
that would be to one response I guess
the other response is um I don't know
when this language came into the statute
but the last time the budget committee
Cooperative School District statute was
revised was in
1996 you know if there's a challenge in
one in one Cooperative School District
then there may be a challenge in one
particular Cooperative School District
but moving in on 30 years this doesn't
seem to have been a significant issue
Statewide I I all question no it was
actually more of a statement so I would
pass are there any further question yes
represent
Tanner um would articles or uh questions
that are voted on in the budget
committee possibly be different than
what's voted at the whole school board
meeting could you could you repeat that
again I missed the first part of that
representative would the would the
questions that that the budget committee
is voting on
on my from my experience we have little
almost straw pole votes on different
things that are small parts of the
budget and then you have your final
budget overall vote right that's much
different or could be much different
than the school board what they're
actually voting on except for the final
vote which is the school budget which is
should be like set a compromise between
that budget yeah so thank you for the
question representative I mean I I
suppose I suppose it could work that way
and and and and if that's sort of been
the practice with your budget committee
and your community where you know the
bucom is sort of voting on chunks if you
will or it will take the 1,000 line
items today we'll take the 2,000 line
items you know next week so on and so
forth um yeah that that that that that's
a reasonable Point as to why there may
be why the school board member um may
have a a separate vote as you're working
through the process through the budget
committee the other thing too um and
this is sort of off topic not related to
your question but I a I apologize but it
thought about it earlier it just popped
in my head again um while we know that
the there are statutory requirements
relative to budget committees under RSA
32 14 15 16 whatever they are um and
then they relate to RSA 195 Co 12a um I
can't think of the co-ops offand and we
know we've had a lot of discussion about
coopertive school districts in this room
the last seven or eight years um some
articles of agreement going back back to
like the' 60s have budget committees
within them um and and and through those
articles of agreement those budget
committees may have certain rights
obligations responsibilities that may be
a little bit more broad if you will or
different than what the statutory
requirements um necessarily allow for
what RSA 32 necessarily allows for so
you may have articles of agreement that
give that person voting rights so you're
going to have a conflict of laws in
there whether or not the voters to come
back and amend their articles of
agreement that create their own internal
their own bucom um within their
Cooperative School District that that
may be in violation or or contrary to
what a statutory language may may
include I thought I wasn't going to have
to pull all those articles of agreement
out of my file system well if if if and
if I could representative L just stand
we've got more bills would just take
another minute I was going to think I
get I think we've got one more Co-op
Bill about the the voting mechanisms um
some some of you are probably really
sick of me hearing this once again an
hsba um will advocate for a 2-year long
study commission to look at RSA 195 in
it's totality chairman lad I know you
and I had had that conversation quite a
bit over the over the last few years I
understand why that may not be an option
but just to get it on their record that
still is on hba's recommendation that we
do a S study Commission on RSA 195 and
its
totality
yeah we've gone to the ringer on this
yeah
Mr cordelli beside me myself it's been a
long
trip it has um okay so is any more
questions for the New Hampshire school
boards
Association thank you very much thank
you very much Mr chair so on this
bill let's see it doesn't look like we
have any more cards on this bill this
642 here and we had that so with that
we're going to close the hearing and the
hearing is next one's up
at 1:45 so we have a 15minute break I
thought this was going to go longer
co-ops are usually very
controversial maybe we always ought to
hold these things in the afternoon when
it's cold
outside all righty
sir how many people in the committee are
in a
co-op I'm in one how many towns do you
have
in
yeah and cure sge
yeah
Springfield
yeah yeah I'm in a co-op in
hail which has one town in it and seven
at large
members yeah I don't these aren't really
controversial
today are we getting down the membership
though do we have anything on membership
yeah this one is about
vacancies
e
we have today it's HB
1481 relative to appointments to fill
vacancies to a l at large Cooperative
School Board
seats one thing we need to be aware of
all these co-ops are
different so it's not one size fits all
here so representa spiber you're welcome
come tell us about your
Co-op thank you Mr chairman good
introduction I'd like to introduce hb1
1481 relative to appointments to fill
vacancies to at Large large Cooperative
Schoolboard seats so I bring you the
experiences of Fall Mountain and you
guys will uh subject it to your broad
experience
uh the
balance in Schoolboard
composition varies from District to
district and it's usually something that
has a lot of history in the case of Fall
Mountain where the Cooperative District
was created in
1966 out of five prior districts each
representing one of the five constituent
towns we have a School Board of seven
five of the seats are assigned to uh the
individual
towns and two of them are at large how
those at large seats are held makes an
enormous difference in terms of the
decision making and the dynamic between
the towns Charles town has about 45% of
the uh
Ada um Bears about 45% of the budget
although we have an
extraordinarily complicated I've been
told by state doe that we have the most
complicated uh allocation uh formulas
there's something like seven or 10
different formulas within the
articles but generally speaking
Charlestown Bears 45% of the
cost and we have a very different
Dynamic and a very different profile in
our town than the other four towns it is
very
typical that Charles toown will vote
something one way and the other four
towns with their 55% will aggregate to
overwhelm Charlestown this is going to
come up in the next billal here as well
so the purpose of this
bill is that specifically
midterm vacancy specifically an atlarge
seat it says when a vacancy occurs in
any Cooperative School Board seat that
is elected at large any successor
appointed to fill the vacancy shall be
domiciled in the same municipality as
the outgoing member was at the time of
their
elections I wouldn't be bringing you
this bill unless I hadn't seen
repeatedly um how it plays out if it is
typical where we have
for Charlestown to hold one of the
atlarge
seats and for Walpole to hold another
wple is about 2third the size of
Charlestown the other three towns are
considerably
smaller so when a
Charlestown uh representative holds an
outlar seat and resigns midterm you
wouldn't think it happens that often but
it's happened several times in the last
few
years um what this bill would say is for
the balance of that term the appointment
power of the remaining select board
members is restricted to choosing a
candidate from that Community to
maintain the balance that the voters
established at the last election now of
course every uh several years when the
the term comes up it's back to the
voters to decide who's the best
candidate and where they're going to
come from but it's no accident in a
district like ARS that it is almost
invariably two at llarge seats one held
by a Charlestown resident one held by a
Walpole resident and yet repeatedly when
a Charlestown resident has resigned
midterm the school board has moved to
seat somebody from another
town this is
all decision Dynamics based on balance
of
power thank you very much are there any
questions of Representative spillsbury
uh yes representative Tanner thank you
and thank you for taking my question so
uh in your
scenario there's still a Charlestown
representative right because you're just
talking about at large seats in
Charlestown would if the Charlestown
representative that's one of the
five bails out then they have they have
to do a Charlestown one so there'll
always be at least one Charlestown
person on that
that's correct there there would never
be fewer than one Charlestown
representing charlestown's 45% interest
okay thank
you within your articles of agreement if
you have them now some co-ops do not
have articles of
agreement so does it spell out how this
is to be done within your articles of
agreement it spells out that each prior
district will have one representative
and that there will be two at large it
does not spell this out the replacement
no it it has no language either
addressing or conflicting with this Bill
thank you further
questions thank you very
much thank you uh bar
Christina thank you chairman lad members
of the committee um repres pres of
spillsbury and I thought about just
doing a point counter point um uh but I
I I joke I hope you take a little humor
in that uh we are opposed to the bill um
primarily um the language that says um
it has to be from the same
municipalities the outgoing member at
large is at large that's the that's the
Cooperative as a as a single entity
whether or not that's a two Town Co-op
three Town Co-op Five Town Co-op at
large means at large the other aspect
too relative to this bill and I I I I I
get it I I know that you are
elected if you're in a co-op School
Board member If You're Not Elected at
large you are representing to some
degree that particular community and
hsba goes through significant lengths
when we're doing our trainings when
we're talking to school board members
and well yes you have an obligation to
the voters in your town that elected you
your obligation is to the co-op as an
entity as the whole all the kids all the
towns all the money it it it the the
sort of the the the the bifurcating by
that time in this town is is is not does
not always lead to the best educational
outcome so um again we're opposed to the
bill at large means at large it should
be within the provisions of either the
the select board and the the the the the
following paragraph or whether or not
it's a school board cooperate School
Board that's replacing the appointment
they should be able to choose from
whichever Community they choose that's
what at large means um happy to answer
any questions are there any
questions represent
whitcock thank you chair um
thank you uh
Mr uh I'm I'm kind of confused I'm I'm
only seeing that the change is and I may
being wrong Barrett the only change I'm
seeing is is the the uh bow on 15 and 16
and you talking about the L thank you
for the question represent if you look
at lines three through five that's new
language amend RSA 190 I'm on line two
amend RSA 1959a by inserting after so
that's that's the provision that nsba
specifically objects to the the
provision with the Bold language um the
follows line 7 through 18 or whatever we
don't have a a specific issue with per
se um one point though that I will say
um be mindful so if you look at RSA I'm
sorry if you look at line 16 where it
says um you know the requirements under
RSA 19519 a paragraph 8 VI I I I if you
look at the next bill we have coming up
um House Bill 13 83 um this removes one
of those paragraphs and would only get
down to um
A6 so both both these were to patch
they're going to have there's going to
be somebody in the clerk's office is
going to have to figure out what the
what they mean by rewriting one of the
statutes but um anyway um so I hope that
clarified representative Woodcock yeah
thank you thank you very much
so the best of your knowledge do when a
this occurs in other
co-ops is the do they usually put app
point a person to fill out the rest of
that
year from a person that lives in that
same district I I to be honest with your
representative I have no idea I mean I
don't if somebody's appointed to a
school board I don't know how and why
and where I just they we get an email
that you know Rick lad is a new school
board member can you here's his email
address can you sign him up for for your
emails we don't ask how and why um you
know I mean again how how depending on
however that that they have to be
appoint if there's a vacancy it has to
be appointed presumably within the
context of what your articles of
agreement say relative to your
representation I believe the
representative said that in Fall
Mountain each of the five towns has one
seat excuse me and then there are two at
large seats so if a person that was um
holding you know the aworth seat
resigned thenum that person has to be
from aworth the replacement does to to
to to satisfy the conditions and terms
of your articles of agreement but if
it's an at llarge seat that becomes
vacant that they're representing all
five communities so why can't the person
be selected from wherever they're
selected
from or problem or why if the person
that's leaving was an elected
member that to fill that year that that
person's vacating wouldn't be taking the
position that that first elected member
had you know won and served as to
replace somebody from that same district
right yeah I mean you know again it it
it it it's going to depend on what your
articles of agreement say if everybody
is elected at
large you know if your Co if your
articles of agreement say that all
school board members are going to be
elected at large it doesn't matter what
town or Community you're you're
specifically from you know I mean I
don't think there are many district any
many c-ops that do all at large I think
most of them are yours well yours may be
a little bit different though you're a
one toown Co-op
so which is its own
animal all at large right so um anyway I
I hope that helps okay thank you any
further questions thank you very much
thank
you we have another
break
o' at night
wow
okay we're ready to go ahead with it 215
we're going ahead with HB
1383 this is relative to Cooperative
Schoolboard District elections
represent prom
O'Brien no no
no that's next under different 1383 oh
yeah okay where's the other card then I
thought she was oh you know I'm sorry
sorry I've been sitting there this whole
time and you don't have the card in okay
so I thought I will fill it upce
apologize she could probably do or
whatever so I will fill it out when you
leave yeah thank you I
apologize it's like
me I know better me too just too many
things in the
head go
ahead thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee um I am r
representative r Kum from Hillsboro
District 30 I appreciate your time today
here to present uh House Bill
1383 which uh is a bill to to um
hopefully correct The Cooperative School
boards um the election process for uh
members who are at large members and who
are not at large
members uh
and putting together the bill
actually since getting the bill and and
looking at it and talking with others
afterwards um I'm learning that there
may be some confusion on some of these
lines so certainly open to some
suggestions as far as Corrections and I
think that there's already one amendment
that um may be worth putting through but
um my my purpose for this bill is
um in regards to how the Cooperative
articles of agreements have been drafted
or the bylaws have been drafted and how
they're implemented uh if my number is
correct we have 12 cooperatives in the
state cooperatives have a variety of
ways that they're going to build their
their uh Schoolboard composition as I
heard there's one here that has all
members at large uh speaking from the
Hillsboro deerings the district that I
come from we have a five member School
Board One member is uh three members are
at large members and two members are not
the two that are not one is supposed to
be a Dearing resident the other one a
Hillsboro resident the three at large
members um two of them are supposed to
be Hillsboro residents and one is
supposed to be a deing
resident the way that we've been voting
for as long as I could tell on the
records is everybody's voted at large uh
all positions are voted at large so um
deing has come forward with the fact
that they aren't being represented with
their person at the table that is a non-
atlarge member and um and looking at
this and then looking at the other
Cooperative contracts the AR articles of
agreement I've noticed that as we've
progressed in our years
um some of those articles of agreement
are very specific some of them are not
the Hillsboro daring Cooperative started
in
1957 and in 1957 when they started they
just listed these are this is the school
board makeup that we want they did not
actually spend specify that the at large
members are voted at large but the two
others are not where Jeffrey ringe did
go as far as breaking out their school
board and saying X number are coming
from Jaffrey X number are coming from
ringe and only Jeffrey will vote on
jaffre's members and only ringe will
vote on Ring's members and so
on
so the the purpose of this bill is is to
clean that up so that when there is an
article of agreement out there for our
cooperatives and it doesn't specifically
specify the the piece on who's voting
for it but it does does the breakout of
the composition of the school board my
intention here is to clean that
up with the with the wording here um
online item nine of my bill where we've
crossed out all members of The
Cooperative School Board shall be
elected at large we crossed that out and
um originally that was crossed out not
because we don't want to have any
atlarge members that's not what my
intention is is here I I don't want to
get rid of the atlarge
members what it is is that we don't want
all members to be voted on an atla in an
election process at large so
um what was happening with some of our
school districts as they were coming to
this line and they were stopping and
they were creating their ballots in each
of the towns so that all of their
Schoolboard members were being voted on
elected in an atlarge
position um so I think maybe that we can
leave this line but change the word
shall to maybe for those school
districts those School cooperatives
rather that do have a 100% at large um
representation at the
table further down on line um 26 of the
bill uh we had to make a correction RSA
669 is actually referring to a town
election where 671 is the school
district election so uh if if nothing
else that change should be corrected in
our in our
statute
um but I'll open this up for questions I
just I just want to recap so in case I
wasn't clear in this and I use Hillsboro
Dearing um as my example where we have a
a Hillsboro representative at the table
and a daring representative at the table
that are not at large
members my intention is that Hillsboro
number is only voted on by the residents
of Hillsboro and that the daring
resident is only voted on by the
residents of Daring and that the three
at large seats are voted on by both
towns and that that be consistent with
every other Cooperative that doesn't
actually have that spelled out so for
the cooperatives that are listing five
members seven members 12 members all as
at large that doesn't change for the
Cooperative such as Jaffrey and ringe
where they specifically spelled it out
in their Artic articles of agreement
it's a non-issue but there's other
school districts out there that are
following suit with how things are being
done in Hillsboro Dearing that we want
to just clarify that for so that they're
getting the proper representation at the
table and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have for me thank
you very much representative any
questions representative
leus can you explain the change of
nonpartisan to
official that is a recommendation that
was um asked of me through the the
school dist District governance
Association because they have another
bill out there that is um looking to
take away the nonpartisan elections at
the um school I think and Municipal
level so um it was requested that I add
that in there so that if this does pass
and if his passes the two bills are
consistent thank you further questions
represent
whitcock thank you chairman good
afternoon good
hro and daring the two uh system you're
talking about specifically are they uh
both the support of this change yes they
are in fact
uh yes thank you for the question yes
they are they both uh I had members from
both districts come to me to request
this change thank you thank you chair
represent Damon actually if I could
expound a little bit further in fact
that the last election cycle we had um
daring actually voted for or a school
board member so the residents of Daring
picked the person and then after
Hillsboro voted they picked somebody
different so daring came to me and said
here again is why we need to have this
fixed because we are not getting our
representation on at the table we're
getting Hillsboro's
representation yes thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question are
Washington and Winslow Windsor
sorry uh only tuition to Hillsboro
during High School or are they part of
the
Cooperative they are tuition and they're
part of the SAU they're not part of the
Cooperative follow up yes so what kind
of representation do they have on the
Cooperative board if any they don't have
any representation on the Cooperative
board they have their own school board
so they have their own town uh
representation that they hold within
their town for their school board and
then they combine once the SAU so they
have individual Schoolboard
representation in their
Town
Miler thank you Mr chair I need and
thank you for being here could you
clarify what you just said just a minute
ago about Dearing electing
somebody to the board and then they
weren't were they not seated I mean I
what I don't understand what that what
you just said okay thanks for the
question and and I would be happy to
clear that up daring has 1,200
registered voters round numbers um in
their town and Hillsboro has roughly
3,800 registered voters they had two
residents that were running for the
resident seat the non-at llarge seat and
Darren chose the female who was running
and she outnumbered the the gentleman
who was running in the incumbent he's
the
incumbent when we counted in the votes
from Hillsboro because they treated that
as an atlarge vote um the voters of
Hillsboro preferred that the gentleman
the incb
take the seat and did not vote in um
favor of the female so therefore
Hillsboro's voters were able to
outnumber the Dearing voters just by
population of
Voters and they selected the incumbent
rather than the Challenger correct and
this language would change that correct
thank you that is my intention thank you
represent cordelli um thank you thank
you for bringing this forward this is
something that several of us have worked
on
before um unsuccessfully I might add but
um we're hopeful um CU in our local
school district um you have similar
situation in that uh for instance New
Durham and Effingham representatives are
elected by the entire quap District so
the um residents of evingham are always
well very often if not usually
outnumbered in the election by the rest
of the co-op um District
voters um the um and and I think that
gets away with one man one vote uh
concept that we were trying to correct
um but I think one problem and maybe
correct me if you disagree
but in your Roman three is where you're
trying to correct
that provision is is am I reading that
correctly that's correct okay the um
followup
yes um the other thing that we um had
addressed in previous legislation that
um I'm not sure how you see being
handled in in your bill um but we said
that as of such a a future date all
members had to be elected in accordance
with this
statute um whereever whereas you're just
you just have an effective date of 60
days and it um you know the law will
take effect but there won't be an
election you know until who knows when
so I don't think it would be possible to
comply with the effective date without
setting a date by which the district or
the co-ops had to be in compliance with
this new statute um do you see any
problems with the effective
date I viewed it a little differently
um what my intention was here was to
not my intention is to follow the
articles of agreement that are currently
in place and to not be not seek any
changes to what's already out there as
far as what's defined in the Articles of
Incorporation so um or articles of
agreement I'm
sorry so therefore it's to me I just
viewed it as an election process which
means that this wouldn't really require
a long
um effective date process because if the
articles of agreement say that you're
going to have a five- member Board of
which each member is supposed to be from
a specific town and not an at llarge
member then the correction is only those
towns are voting on them if your
articles of agreement or your bylaws
state that you're going to have 12
members at large there's nothing to
change all members stay at large the
voting stays the way that it has and in
the case where we have a mixture um such
as Hillsboro Dearing where we have two
members each representing a town and
three at large seats again there's
nothing to change the correction being
that at the next election cycle which I
would assume is going to be in 2024 I
mean 2025 rather the next election cycle
Hillsboro votes for the Hillsboro
resident daring votes for the daring
resident and the at llarge seats are
voted by both
towns so there's no change yes one more
if I might so then your intent here
would not change the situation in my
Co-op District where Effingham voters
would vote for the Effingham
representative to the school board
that's correct if if your if your seats
are not listed as at large seats then
only the residents of Effingham should
be voting for that and no other Town
should be voting for that
representative um ours is a little
situation is a little different they're
not listed as um at large seats
Effingham seat is an Effingham seat it's
not at large but the entire Co-op
District votes for the Effingham seat
not just Effingham
voters yeah say
that correct so that that falls under
Roman numeral one which online item nine
which it appears that your district is
voting all members to be at large me as
if they're at large members and that's
where I don't think that should apply
and that's the whole point is that your
seats are not designated at large they
should not be voted on that way and in
my opinion thank you I think one of the
things just a comment here you know I'll
get you repr in Bon is that we need to
look at all these agreements and there
are over 30 co-ops in the state and when
you look and there's some co-ops that
don't have articles of
agreement and so there there's a lot to
this puzzle here representative Bon
thank you Mr chair and actually that was
part of my question is why couldn't this
be solved through the articles of
agreement why does it have to be solved
through
legislation that's a loaded
question based upon how they vote and
and the weights
within represent cordelli
correct oh I I wasn't sure who she was
asking
Okay the reason that I believe this
needs to be handled here is because of
Roman numeral one on line one where we
have it written in the and defined in
the Articles of agreement the schools
the cooperatives are choosing to go with
line one where it says all members of
The Cooperative board shall be elected
at large and I think that's what's
creating our problem so therefore I
think that needs to be
corrected pron cascaden thanks would it
would it solve the problem if line one
just read all members of The Cooperative
School Board shall be elected as defined
in the warrants of article
because all the warrants of Articles
might be
different articles of agreement I mean
I'm
not is that question to me or to your
chair I'll ask you could it could it be
done that
simply not in my opinion and in my
opinion it's because in the case of
Hillsboro deing when I looked at their
contract their articles of agreement
they did not although they specified two
seats were not at large and they
specified three were they did not
specify who is to be voting on that so
the it directs to this law as far as how
it should be voted on and they're
choosing to follow line Roman numeral
one that says all members shall be
elected at large represent Cornell Thank
you thank you for taking my question um
line nine Roman will run at the end of
it says or and every one of those says
as POS District as possible or most
nearly achieve or are they just ignoring
the
ores because it says all members of The
Cooperative School Board shall be
elected at large or the Cooperative
School District shall be divided into
or I can only speculate because I I'm
sorry go ahead and finish no I'm sorry I
can only speculate that they may be
ignoring it I don't really know for for
absolute fact but there obviously is
confusion between several school
districts as representative Cordelia is
sharing a similar
experience representative
Woodcock this is probably for you um the
would the article agreement if this
passed with the AR article agreement the
original ones uh suped this
anyhow I'm not an attorney I know that
um but these articles of agreement go
way back into the 60s and even earlier
than that there are districts who have
changed what they're doing even though
their artics agreement say something
contrary I.E my district we had four for
one district and three for the other
District within the same town and for
some reason we're all at large now and I
think it was the town District that had
three couldn't get anybody to run so it
ended up that the all large was coming
from may I ask a question on that do you
happen to know if anybody voted on that
change because I'm running into the same
situation and I can't find where the
public body ever voted to change our
composition that occurred when there
were schools in both ends um we
Consolidated in one in
Woodsville and we're a town about 5,000
people and uh no I can't tell you how
anything functioned that I was chair of
the select board chair of the fire
district all that but I it goes back to
the
days that the town was founded back in
the 1700s
and so it's just it's it's really
difficult to understand some of this and
we did take it and then you know how
people are how their towns are broken up
based upon demographic based on property
valuation based upon some other kind of
denominator numerator you know it's it's
a it's a mess reveres
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking another question that's what you
wanted to would you consider it
reasonable to think that if we didn't
pass this bill or some similar version
of
it in districts where the municipalities
are very different in population size
that the larger communities would always
Prevail in having more
representation I I would think that
that's a fair assumption to make which
is I think the importance of having
articles of agreement when you are
joining forces with a Cooperative school
district oh
didn't like what we doing so this would
somewhat address that that the folks
living in the smaller population
communities would be more assured yeah
potentially more assured of
representation if when they agreed to
get into the Cooperative with another
District knowing full well that that
District or that town or towns were
larger than them and they specified that
they wanted to seat at the table and
that was agreed upon in the Articles of
agreement I believe that it is
reasonable for them to expect that they
have their choice and I think that they
deserve to have their choice at the T to
have their representation at the table
thank you if they agreed to at large
members that was the risk that they
took further questions represent Tanner
thank you I I don't want us to lose um
the vision of the change on line
26 um from
nonpartisan to official which then makes
it partisan seems like we've had a a lot
of
um particularly during the mass no MK
period a lot of contentious school board
meetings and school boards in general
have been having a difficult time I
think actually getting people to run and
really with the local elections like
select board County
Commissioners it's it's basically a
nonpartisan and it's on a nonpartisan
ballot do you see that this little
change is going to make a huge huge
change as far as school boards are
concerned I will say that I'm in
agreement with you I personally am okay
with a nonpartisan and I do believe that
our local election should be nonpartisan
however the reality is they're not and
we know that um so for that reason
because I was understanding the
situation of it not being partisan I I
accommodated the requests from the sdga
because I knew that they were pursuing
the same thing so that we were
consistent but I am certainly open to
changing that back because I do agree
they I I prefer them to remain
nonpartisan thank you further questions
from the committee representative Damon
thank you so on that same um one-word
change what is the definition of
official
ballot I don't I don't know what that
means you know to me an official ballots
an official ballot if the names are on
there whether their party is or their
part is not so um that that can be
pretty broad right but I think the um
expectation when you see official ballot
is to see a side for Republicans a side
for Democrats and maybe a side for those
Independents and Libertarians
and so an official ballot is an official
ballot whether the party is showing or
not
showing further question
representa Tanner I'm just wondering on
the official ballot whether um
independent libertarian green party you
know on and on and on uh would actually
be not you know be notified on an
official ballot um or whether they can
run for those positions you know
um I don't make the ballots so um yeah
so I don't I don't create the official
ballot the official ballot to me by my
definition would be the ballot that is
handed to me when I walk into the the
voting booth me too thank you very much
uh any further questions thank you very
much for introducing the
bill
uh going on uh representative prud
O'Brien thank you thank you all for your
time sharing your expertise on these
matters
I first heard about this bill a few days
ago when I got a call from my school
moderator at in the Dairy Cooperative
School District that's a school district
all within Dair uh K through
8 and it's I guess it's that's what
makes it a little unusual and different
than what you're all talking about my
best guess is that there used to be
other towns a long time ago a very long
time before my memory that there used to
be other towns and that's how it got the
term Cooperative School
District uh my my school moderator
called and said that she likes this bill
that's Tina
Guilford but she wanted a little bit
more clarification about how it would be
implemented if so if it would be a
staggered implementation where say a
town has six districts would it be the
even numbered districts one year the odd
numbered districts the next year or
would it be every District all at
once it doesn't address it in this bill
that I see so I think that's what it
would mean is all at once and she would
just like a little bit more
clarification on that and I can answer
some questions as best as I possibly can
thank thank you very much okay uh are
there any
questions not seeing but the the bill we
were dealing with that representative
cordellia we were putting in a
transition process it's pretty hard to
say it's going to happen on day one it's
all going to change um it's very
difficult um seeing no other questions
we'll call up representa spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman do I get a do you
have a frequent flyer
program triple miles mostly I'm going to
be an echo here I can be relatively
brief I put in an LSR to do essentially
the same thing and um representative
culen beat me to the punch so I became
her first
co-sponsor my concern is the primary one
that she
expressed and that is where articles of
agreement designate a seat specifically
to represent a town or a prior District
only the members the voters of that
Community should elect their own
representative and I can tell you that
in Fall Mountain
um there are five towns and there are
five individual seats assigned one each
and two at large as I described before
but all seven are voted across the board
at large by all of the um voters in the
district so where you have an atlarge
seat representing the district it makes
sense that all the voters of the
district should vote at large we're
using the term at large in two different
ways
representation versus who gets the
vote those have to be separated when it
comes to the seats that represent the
individual
towns so I have
seen repeatedly the dynamic where a
candidate in a contested election for
the charl town seat prevent prevails in
Charlestown with a majority
vote and the
runnerup uh then prevails in the
election because the voters from the
other four towns choose a different
person I have seen that happen several
times I've also seen it happen where the
voters of
Charlestown have as uh representative
Miler was getting that
before selected a CH allenger to an
incumbent but the other four towns have
voted for the incumbent so where
Charlestown was trying to displace
somebody to put in in effect a
substitute they were
prevented I would also say in in our
district um to representative Damon's
question of a of Representative
culcom the fact that Charlestown has 45%
does not allow Charlestown to presume it
will its view will prevail because in
fact the
55% taking the other four towns together
is the
majority but further uh comment because
I don't want this to sound like it's
exclusively from a Charlestown Centric
point of
view we have 45% of the
voters Walpole has about
30 st's a little less than um 20 and
langon and and aworth are in the single
digits why should the 45% of the
electorate from Charlestown be able to
tell Lil aworth who their representative
is or langon so in the same way I want
the voters of Charlestown to designate
their representative I don't want the
voters of Charlestown to tell langner
aworth who they should have we're
talking about dramatic disparities there
are just under 5,000 um residents I
don't know the the um uh the voter count
in Charlestown and there are 800 in
aworth so if they're intended to
represent the individual town or prior
District then we need to elect them in
that way that's the proposition of the
bill I would I would just say as a
couple of technical points if you look
at the caption uh with the analysis
rather on the first page the bill
requires Cooperative School Board to
elect representatives from pre-existing
districts only from voters within the
district stop there that's clear that's
what I'm
endorsing and prohibits the atlarge
election of all members that's
problematic um and I think that there
will probably this bill should be passed
but it should be cleaned up and you will
probably need an amendment to address
striking out of uh line
nine there are districts that have all
at large members I'm a little bit
confused I think it may have been
representative cascaden or Bon who
raised the question about the
ores if you look at the language in the
statute before the Amendments shall be
limited this is in lines five and six
shall be limited to the Alternatives
contained
herein and that means each of the of
these uh listed paragraphs is an
independent alternative I haven't
thought through how those really
interact but I think just striking one
is problematic I also think that the
question of nonpartisan versus official
is extraneous to the key point of the
bill I would urge you to stay focused on
the key point of the bill if I can do
anything to help any member of this
committee redraft I'm available um but
uh please take a strong enough interest
in it to clean it up and pass
it thank you very much are there any
questions representative Tanner thank
you thank you for taking my question
does on in Fall Mountain does aworth
have a representative on the school
board and Langdon have a separate
representative on the Schoolboard each
town has their own so yes to aworth yes
to langon and allstead Walpole and
Charlestown okay and so Char Charlestown
with its 4,800 voters has a seat the
same as aworth does with 800 voters I
believe acworth's total student count
currently is about 24 that's true so
they have a lot of influence on the
school board with one out of seven seats
guaranteed thank you further
questions thank you very much it's
important to note that there are some
co-ops like the one the town of Carol is
in which Carol's very small but Carol's
being asked to pay 40 Grand per pupil to
carry the burden for the co-op and and
then vice versa we had um a town which
the previous chair of ways and means
didn't want anything changed but this
town had the highest property values and
all and and and paying the tab and they
wanted to control that so there there's
a lot of angles which we're going to
have to consider on this uh uh
representative Barrett Christina Barrett
he's been up here every time
today
yeah thank you again chairman lad
members of the committee um we're
opposed to the bill but I do want to
thank the prime sponsor for coming in
and giving a a good explanation of sort
of the reasoning and rationale within
her within her District that helped me
sort of clarify um at least have a
better understanding as as to where the
the bill was coming from and sort of the
purpose and and behind that um as always
so uh when we have the bills relative to
the election of Cooperative School Board
um members um my first question is
always have the voters considered any of
the other options that are available to
them under the existing statute I
believe there are four or five Options
under current law on how Cooperative
school board members can be elected at
large a district um You Know A District
uh proportional
representation um the current provision
which is current uh uh paragraph four
which is looking to be amended you know
have have have the voters had an
opportunity to wait on amending the
articles of agreement to change to
change the how they're going to be
elected locally that's always the first
aspect um we would certainly object to
the elimination of of of um the atlarge
provision in in in paragraph one I'm
sorry in uh line nine um which is
current law paragraph one um and we
object to the the change um at the end
of from the nonpartisan ballot system to
the official uh ballot system I'm aware
of that bill I I forget the bill number
but it's basically a local option where
the voters could um determine whether or
not they wanted their Local School Board
elections um to be partisan where I
presume that means you'd have to file
with a with a political party um you
know I would say that we have um too
much politics in in in public education
respectfully to all of you but you know
my members live it every day we don't
need to exacerbate that by any means um
but again um you know I it
nhba were opposed to the bill the idea
of of having you know the the voters in
Hillsboro vote for the Hillsboro rep and
the voters for having endearing voting
for The Dearing rep I think there's
certainly some Merit to that um we would
have to be mindful of the other sort of
impact though that it may have on
articles of agreement I mean I I I I
need to go back and research sort of the
one man one vote principle and and some
of the case law that's come out from
this but if we have a a a town that has
4,000 th000 people in a town that has
2,000 people and we're looking for prop
proportional representation do we have
to change the articles of agreement so
that town with 4,000 people has two reps
then and the town with 2,000 people only
has has has one rep then I'd have to do
some more research on that but that
would be a concern that that I would
have as well too um and then last it's
already been talked about sort of the
Staggering in of of of how this would
how this would would would take effect
because we know March elections are in
March that person's elected to a
three-year seat but then if the Law
changes we need to figure out some
whether staggering or whatever it might
be you'd have to you'd have to build in
some lead time probably probably over
the course of about three or four years
I would say um in order for that to to
sort of um be actualized so um those are
those are NH hba's comments let's let's
always try fixing it locally first I
local Solutions in my opinion have or
local problems have local Solutions most
of the time um I understand that there's
more than one Co-op that may be impacted
by this but um you know I would
encourage the school boards um to maybe
look at what other options are available
to them before we we move forward with
with changing legislation with that I'm
Happ to answer any questions Miler thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here I need
clarification the role of the Articles
of of agreement Visa State
Statute wouldn't it it seems to me that
if there's a
problem with the article of agreement
locally that those ought to be amended
first because they're particularly
targeted at a particular problem within
that Co-op rather than coming here and
trying to have a statute so that's my
confusion on why aren't we addressing
these at the local level first before
trying to address something that from a
statute standpoint clarify that thank
thank you very much uh represent of nhba
would agree with those sentiments if the
if if the voters in a co-op have
concerns over you know the funding
mechanism proportionality property taxes
student enrollment you can amend the you
can amend the the the articles of
agreement to fix that um you know same
thing with the elections if if if the
voters in that Co-op are not crazy with
the way that the election methods are
occurring based on their current
articles of agreement amend the articles
of agreement or have a study commission
locally not through this body but have a
local study committee to examine what
options are available to us let's bring
in the attorneys to talk about the one
man one vote get a legal opinion about
how the representation may work out um
you know and and there's another thing
aspect to this too and um you know I'm
not naive enough to to ignore sort of
this town and this town and who's paying
more in taxes and they've got more kids
but our per pupil is higher I I
understand that from a local taxpayer
property owner samp point I understand
that um but sort of as I mentioned I
think it was on on on on the first Bill
about the co-op as a single entity
serving all the kids together within
that school district and I I don't need
to I I won't waste anybody's time we
talked about this a couple years ago and
some members were on the committee some
members were not about sort of the long
history of co-ops and why were why they
were started to begin with um and the
regionalization you know to save
administrative cost um to save building
cost so on and so forth um so let's not
let's not necessarily presume that um
you know just because this town has the
most more voters than this town that
they're trying to you know stick it to
the little guy or stick it to the small
town I don't think that's anybody's
intent I me I understand that you know
you're going to look at your property
taxes first I I totally get that but in
the context of a of a Cooperative School
District where we're trying to educate
all the kids and all these communities
hopefully there's a general sentiment
that you know what's good for one is
good for all and what's good for all is
good for the rest of
us thank you very much is it not true
that when these articles of agreement
were written years ago that now the
dynamic in those communities has
significantly changed Y and
so we did we not try to change and put
into the statute that we've been talking
about here several years back yeah an
understanding that the articles of
agreement had to be updated in a certain
period a time period five years 10 years
every 10 years or so thank you for the
question representative we certainly had
that discussion that did not make it in
into law though um I think we there were
some conversation about reviewing it
every 10 years in accordance with um
that latest decade census um to you know
if you have to reapportion the number of
seats um that's my recollection I mean I
know it's not in law but we had that
conversation
yeah question yeses
Woodcock once again thank you for coming
um go follow and representative Milo
this question was someone I asked before
G asked before which FES precedent there
the the article agreement or the RSA
yeah thank you very much I mean the
articles of agreement have to be in
accordance with the statute you know um
you know my understanding is that the
most most of the times that this that
the articles of agreement have been
amended it's usually
your your your your cost you know what
district is paying what and based on
what formula um you know I haven't done
a review of all 32 articles of agreement
but the fact that some of these articles
of agreement predate the current
statutes they probably some areas and
some of them where where the articles of
agreement are not in full compliance
with with the current with the current
statute but I also again without having
reviewed RSA 195 and its entirety
probably since last year when we had a
co-op bill you know the that statute is
is not gives a lot of flexibility to the
locals to craft their own their own
articles their own contract essentially
but I mean the state law would always
take would always take precedent and the
articles of agreement have to fit within
that but without again without having
looked at the what the articles of
agreement have to specifically contain
it may list you know has to contain
these 10 things but how that's done is
is is a local is a local determination
thank you thank thank you R luus you had
your hand
up yeah talking about the effective date
it seems to me that this is talking
about
elections and that therefore it could go
into effect right away because it
wouldn't have any effect until the next
election and so each election so it
seems like it would naturally phase in
just because
you know at each election because of the
election cycle yeah yeah I mean that
that's I suppose that's possible
representative excuse me um yeah I I
suppose that's possible but I I think
it's certainly a consideration now we'd
have to find out the mechanics of of how
it worked you know so if it says if we
eliminate you know if we well we'd have
to we'd have to give it some thought as
to as to how to implement that thank you
thank you
further questions thank I I'll just ask
him out thank you very much thank you no
further question thank you very much
close this hearing and go into the next
one for today
um uh HB 1579 relative to the merging of
school administrative
units
we need to break out that old bill we
had I sent you the amendment that we did
okay good and so this is the how we
transitioned yeah I remember that in
accordance with the statute by such and
such date vile a preliminary transition
plan to the state board by such and such
date and if members expire earlier than
they elected pursu to this statue yes
see and we that was a pretty good plan
too
y get
building yeah
okay okay 1579 relative merging of
school administrative districts I
welcome represent
attorney thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee there are
currently 107 public school
administrative units saus in the state
not including Charter School saus of
which there are 31 more the salaries for
superintendents and assistant
superintendents plus business managers
for the public school saus totals 29,8
75,4
196 for those who responded to the 2023
New Hampshire Department of Education
division of Education analytics and
resour Bureau of educational
statistics three saus did not respond
for five positions and one SAU gave an
hourly rate for one
position these amounts do not include
such positions as secretaries accounts
payable accounts receivable and any
other positions in the SAU offices nor
any other expenses for the SAU such as
ran electricity phones computers and
anything else necessary to run the
office superintendent salaries range
from
15,500 to a high of
192,193 superintendent gets paid
$135,000 I'm not sure how that worked
out SAU student population ranges from
approximately 40 students to a high of
about 12,000 students students per se
staff member ranges from a low of 15 to
a high of
747 sa37 which is Manchester which has
the largest student
population 141 students per SAU staff
member in Coos County we have five
saus co uh SAU 7 in colbrook 58 in North
umberland 36 White Mountains Regional 20
is gorum and sa3 is Berlin these five
saus have a combined student population
of
3,299 students and an average student to
SAU staff of
71.5 there are 10 saus with a student
population larger than the Stu total
student population of the five saus in
Coos the five saus in
Coos have I get the right
one
4613 and I've got no idea who that
1.13 person
is uh but of those that's the total
staff for all five five two positions
per superintendent and business manager
or finance manager which is another one
calls it of those five totals
$983,000
but that's only for 10 positions there
are still 36.3 positions plus rent
utilities Etc that will add to that
number if we went down to one SAU up
north
there is currently that all of you have
I believe it's been passed out uh an
amendment to this this amendment came
about after discussions with uh a
gentleman from the Department of
Education and uh this is simply four
from the original Bill uh where uh uh
numeral two says new paragraph school
administrative units that's where the
amendment begins and it goes through to
just before number three which says
effective date these were items uh that
were uh let's say uh not typos but just
uh lack of communication where we used
to say school districts on in the uh
Bill uh line nine and uh was pointed out
to us that should say sa and that's one
of the things the amendment changed and
then they added two extra sections uh d
and e uh after item C which used to be
line
16 uh and that has to do when the number
of students for the SAU the merged SAU
would be
counted uh and on recommendation from
the gentleman from uh doe we picked uh
October first and apparently there's
another count they do at that time I do
not remember what he told me uh and then
uh uh they wanted uh item e also added
into it
uh and uh so that everybody gets the uh
$200 and that was another question what
if uh conquered were to merge with a
smaller um SAU next to it would the new
merged unit would let's say all
13,000 or thereabouts students get the
$200 yes they would because they're a
merged unit it's going to be $200 for
the merged unit per pupil they get that
for two
years uh Plus at the same time they're
saving one or more SAU administrative
costs that would go away they would keep
that permanently for years 3 four five
and
on this bill is offering an in uh
incentive to any saus that wish to merge
with another in order to in order to
lessen their expenses and get an extra
Grant of $200 per student in the merged
SAU for a two-year period there is no
you must or you shall just the
opportunity to those that wish to
merge thank you and if I will take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions representative Heath thank
you this has been an issue that's been
discussed time times before according
speak um and it makes a lot of sense I
mean I know when I was assistant
superintendent I did a study and we came
out um saving at least $100,000 and that
was a lot of years ago um but people
want to have their own district and it
just never seems to happen in the North
Country it makes absolute sense that
they'd have one super superintendent to
carry out those duties so how are you
what have you done to build the
awareness of the communities around this
in your North in your North
Country before I answer that part one of
the things the speaker told me when at
lunch uh in the four or five previous
times it was not optional for the saus
to merge those bills that came before is
you will that's apparently why they
failed this one says if you want to you
can and if you do here's an incentive if
you get above 1500
students uh now as far as the North
Country goes uh I would say now for the
last two or three
years uh sau7 in colbrook has been
attempting to
merge uh they've been attempting to
merge even across state lines uh and go
that way um but they know they've got to
cut down on uh their uh amounts uh if
all the saus in the North Country if I
remember correctly SAU uh seven has the
largest staff I believe they've got 10
there are two that have
eight uh the one I'm in 58 has
six
and uh
can't remember what the other one had oh
14.3 that's where the 0.13 comes in uh I
don't know who that person is but uh
they are working on
it yes um the idea that we want local
control well it's two towns away maybe
three towns away it's still local we've
got fewer people in Coos County than
portsmouth's
got uh yet we have five saus they have
one so people think about it it's just
we believe the incentive might be a
slight nudge to get them to hey maybe
we'll do
it I hope so Doo thank you very much are
there further questions representa
Tanner thank you um I'm just interested
in in who you're counting as staff is it
like the transportation director is that
part of the SAU staff is the uh special
ed director part of the SAU
staff hold on a minute ma'am and I can
tell you this came from the Department
of Education they're counting
superintendents assistant
superintendents Finance professionals
instructional
support uh other
non-instructional these are the titles
they've got clerical other support and
they came up with the totals for the
saus uh which uh uh for example the
conquered SAU office has
52.7 total staff members in it of that
52.7 one SAU superintendent two
assistant
superintendents two Finance
professionals 2.9 instructional support
25.3 other
non-instructional 10 clerical 9 and a
half other support for the 52.7 and this
comes from the Department of Ed for
every single uh SAU just yes um from my
experience the like the transportation
was a really big SIU uh staff um or at
least it was housed there also the
grounds and maintenance uh were all con
you know centered into those things and
when I look at at at um the North
Country I mean Transportation must be I
know for our school because it was a
Cooperative Transportation was like huge
because it we had such a wide area so
the amount of mileage seems to be you
know a really big thing for those
districts I can say for the uh my SAU
which is uh
58 um I've been up there for coming up
on 22 years and as far as I know they
have never had a transport
individual in the SAU office either the
uh SAU superintendent handled it or uh
the business manager handled it on as
part of their duties but there was no uh
Transportation director or anything like
that further questions yes represent
Damon thank you thanks for taking my
question I'm wondering what the basis of
the 15 00 student minimum for a merged
district is I just added up the student
population of the three
towns that some folks in my area might
think should go back to being one school
district they're three saus now there
used to be five towns in that SAU it
doesn't add up to 1,200 never mind 1500
but it would be a cost savings it would
be a cost savings and thank you for your
question right now there
are find where I wrote it
64 saus out of
107 that have fewer than 1,500 students
yeah so you're looking at
60% of all the
saus could merge and get larger any of
the larger ones could easily merge with
a smaller one and they would still pick
up the benefit of it uh up North Country
yeah it would
take if Berlin wasn't one of the ones
merging it would take all the other five
basically to other four to get to, 1500
students
yes so would you consider an amendment
to put the number the minimum number of
students in a restructured district to
be 1,200 so that more small communities
could access this the three of us that
wrote the Bill uh and one of them sits
on the uh committee here with you uh we
agreed that anything above a thousand
would be a savings for most of the
smaller
sius uh so any number in that range uh
we would be agreeable to if uh a change
was wished at the committee thank
you any further
questions not seeing thank you very much
thank you uh bar
Christina chairman L I'm withdrawing my
card um uh nhsb is not taking position
on this bill and we don't have any
testimony great thank you very much so I
have no other cards on this uh bill so
we're going to close the hearing on this
bill and go into the last uh hearing for
the
day and this is
1195 relative to allowing school
districts to approve different
apportionment methods for school
administrative unit
costs
and okay we got the
card representative
David your yes
yeah
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the
committee I'll set go okay sorry for the
record my name is representative David
Muse I represent Rockingham District 37
which includes Newington Newcastle and
Wards 1 and five in Portsmouth
HB 1195 essentially allows school
districts more flexibility to implement
alternative funding formulas and
apportionment methods for their saus as
long as they're mutually agreeable to
the other member
communities communities like Newington
would like to have more flexibility to
discuss alternatives to the current
state-mandated one-size fits-all SAU
funding model with fellow SAU
communities the goal of the legislation
is to better address unique tax based
considerations and student enrollments
within those communities the Newington
Board of Selectmen has asked me to put
this bill forward and since I am not uh
the experts that you folks are in issues
like this uh especially when it comes to
things like school funding apportionment
issues uh Town attorney Paul Des shanes
is here today to testify and provide
some additional background uh and answer
your questions uh so I would defer any
questions uh to Mr Des shanes fine thank
you very much
uh so are there any questions for the
representative that are not the
technical type no okay so we'll we'll
switch hits
here
Paul good afternoon
thank you for this opportunity uh my
name is Paul desan and I am here on
behalf of the town of Newington uh I
will correct one uh statement made by
representative M I am not an attorney uh
I'm a staff member uh of the community
um but with over 30 years of Municipal
experience uh here in New Hampshire so
um I'm not going to uh read the uh uh
letter of support that the board of
selectman submitted and I just passed
around um because there's really only
three main points to this uh legislation
one is that it's only enabling
legislation stop mandating anybody to do
anything it just corrects the SE my
second Point what seems to be an
inconsistency in the current statute uh
if you look at um 194
C2 uh it speaks to how you form an SIU
how you reorganize an SIU how you
withdraw from an SIU and there's a
committee that's esta established and
and particularly under the U
reorganizing it speaks to many different
top topics including how to finance uh
the SAU that's in direct conflict with
um 94 C9 which is where this bill seeks
to amend that is very prescriptive it
says it must be funded one half by based
on enrollments and one half on uh the
assessed values of the member
communities all we're looking for is an
ability to have that discussion uh and
allow mutually agreeable terms uh to
fund our SAU costs uh the current
statute although appears to give you
that that ability because the
prescriptive danger of uh 94 C9 um
you're not permitted to to really fully
invest yourselves in that I draw that
parallel lastly in making my point is
that if you go to the Cooperative uh
School statute uh it has very similar
language that what we're pro proposing
it speaks to 1 half uh assess value one
half enrollments or any alternative uh
that the member communities and a
Cooperative can agree to we're just
looking for that parallel construction
uh for the SIU uh statutes so knowing
I'm between you and the door I'll leave
it at that you've had a long day and I
answer any questions any questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you are there any other pink
cards or any testimony from anybody do
you have anything
Mark Mark's from the Department of
Education Finance was a little too late
with my card on the last bill um but the
SAU merger Bill U Mark Mello Department
of Education I was working with the
representative to add some of those
technical changes um if you're going to
design a grant the what I always tell
members of this committee is you got a
clearly Define student um for us to
calculate that Grant so there's a couple
technical changes that um were passed
out in front of you um to make the bill
um if it were to be enacted something
the department could Implement um so I'm
just uh available if there's any
technical questions on the previous
bill could you explain the technical
thing I I don't have any so so the two
things uh the main things were always
defining student and so the bill as
introduced didn't Define adma or admr so
always need that cleared up for us um
otherwise we'll take a guess um or do
our best best guess to determine what
what is the student measurement um also
chck picking a particular date and so
the date was October 1st count um the
next um area we wanted cleaned up if it
were to be enacted and become law is the
whether the big District would get the
the big SAU merging with the small SAU
whether both of them um would receive
the Grant and so the proposal makes it
clear as the sponsor um intended was
that both saus the kind of the bigger
one merging with the little one both of
them would receive the aid amount um
so thank you represent Miler thank you
Mr chair thank you for being
here what's the incident rate your
office gets regarding school districts
that may want to merge or form together
a different system is is it is it
rampant is it isolated what what's
what's the status of that uh we do get
um relative
to a portion question so there's there's
different types of mergers so with SAU
um the RSA 194c we do get a couple of
those questions um uh more like
technical assistance questions about how
to do that SAU assessment as far as SAU
is discussing it's or gossiping about uh
uh merging or or or unmerging um or
breaking up um
it probably once a year people talk
about it um I know I think this
committee probably talks about the um
saus that want to merger or uh parse out
uh
uh I would say probably but not but not
that often I maybe like once or twice a
year I would say thank you I don't think
we've had many bills referencing this
particular merger we do know that over
in Maine where they have sads school
administrative districts
the only one that merged in the last few
years was uh Rumford Mexico on the other
side of the Andrew gagen River up your
way represent kiss Kaden and in Vermont
there was a bill put forward to do this
and they found some reverse things over
there as a result of some the merch it
was costing more
money so but I don't think i' I've not
had ail like this to merge
SA I don't think we've had that no no in
fact I think the main experience was
really the bust that was well for rord
Mexico it was it's kind of logical what
they did and of course it was increasing
property value of course they got you
know the the paper mill Boise and and
then on the other side in Mexico they
got all the retail stores like Walmart
Etc and they're really busting now too
they're growing I mean I I was I knew um
the chair of the school board in York
Maine for example he and I talked about
this and there were all kinds of issues
around um assess value of property and
all that and they just they and he said
not only their District but others did
consider it they looked at it but it
just was uh technically and fiscally it
was pretty impossible yeah so to be more
precise in answering your question
representative Miler um usually the
conversations are about breaking up not
merging so in my three years with the
Department I don't think we've had an sa
merger more just I think we've had one
or two saus break up um so that was
those conversations are usually and it
usually stems from conversations over um
uh communities uh disagreeing on the tax
assessment um in matters like that y
represent Woodcock thank you uh chairman
I'd like to ask a question on
1195 that's okay 119 okay that's go
actually on right yeah
okay thank you for being here um you had
you heard the presentation which pretty
similar to the testimony is there
anything you could for one the committee
about in terms of this type of
rearrangement of financial uh
distributions I I don't I think I've
studied the bill well enough to
know what um what would happen if it was
implemented we tend to stay out of SAU
merger policies the only advice I give
uh when I read the law as currently
written and I don't know how it relates
to this bill um
exactly um I think I think I understand
from hearing the testimony but the way
the law Works currently is the default
SAU agreement is half ADM half EV so you
have to look at the alternative
procedure and so I leave it up to towns
and school districts and their attorneys
to figure out how to adopt the
alternative procedures but the
alternative procedures would be putting
a warrant article to Define an
alternative route to the default route
and I believe the intent of this bill
and I can't speak to it is is just um
putting that up front because I think
the alternative procedure Pro requires a
warant article each year and so I think
this would I believe this bill am I I
corrected this would allow just one war
article instead of ongoing War article
is that
the if I yes um as I understand the
statute is that prescriptive and is only
the default um so so communities don't
even have the ability to even consider a
war article yearly annually or or or
whatever other term so um this is
enabling that discussion at a local
perod come of a local Solutions and I
don't recall that the uh 9c2 requires an
annual warrant article it once the
planning committee is established and it
goes through this process and the SAU as
a whole adopts the amendment so the
advice I give districts and I'm not an
attorney I first tell them to talk to
their attorney but my understanding is
the default is always in play and as
soon as you form that default is
automatically put there if you want to
come up with an alternative procedure
there's a different set of laws with
alternative procedures um but my
understanding with that alternative
procedure is um it has a different War
article process different from the
forming process so I think this
would I yeah I can't speak to it but
this one would this one would probably
this one would probably
get back to the original forming process
um I'd have to study it a little bit
further
to thank you very much Mark further
questions ref C scen I don't if I can go
back but it's a question to Mark was
there a fiscal note on 1579 did I uh
that sorry it's likely in the process um
I don't know where it is in the process
I do have fisal
note I went through the new on and we
didn't get that today okay so yeah it's
definitely not a the bill uh I ran some
numbers
um
uh about 40,000 I I think the most
amount of students say if every small
SAU
joined um the highest amount of a grant
awarded in one year would be 8 million
um I think a lot of saus would struggle
to come up together and and merge so I
don't know um how many people would
apply for the grant because I think one
uh the 1500 uh student thresholds are
going to be challenging um based just
what based on the map of small saus we
have currently um but if Manchester
picked up another school district that
would cost a lot um because all those
Manchester students would be getting Aid
per pupil so it's it's absolutely
indeterminable um but uh so that that
would be the fiscal note but I would I
would um if if you made this over to
house finance I would just tell them to
put some money in the education trust
fund in case anyone applies for this boy
we don't have that much money in the
fund over $200 million is that somewhere
around there right 161 161 y
okay
okay okay thank you very much Mark
appreciate it uh I don't think we have
any other cards so we're going to close
this hearing and close our work for the
day and we will be back the day after
tomorrow tomorrow's voting day everybody
take advantage of that
and have
fun who you V
for